The joe rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by several uncomfortable
things. The first one to talk about when
the strange people that you don't know.
Steve Ronell's here, I don't even
know this dude, hardly I and an end.
I enjoy your show and I'm going to
have to talk about fake vaginas because
that's one of our sponsors.
One of our sponsors is the flashlight,
the number one sex toy for men.
We've heard it was a really close race,
but we don't know who number two is.
You go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight
and you know, I know what you're saying.
Dab My life. Yeah. Number two was a
melon. Say, I don't need that in my life.
I don't know. I'm not in a perverted
person, amount of wicked person,
but you will masturbate. You know you
will. You should masturbate. You know why?
Because life is complicated and
the way the human body's designed,
we're supposed to be breeding at every
possible chance because infant mortality
was so high because people getting
eaten by fucking Jaguars. Okay.
And that's not the world we live in today.
So in order to navigate
through this world,
you've got to navigate with a body that
essentially has the same DNA as those
crazy monkey people,
dodge and Jaguars from 10,000 years ago.
But that's not you anymore.
Okay.
You live in a complicated society and
you're going to masturbate. So go.
I think the number one sex toy
is proudly the blowup doll.
Wouldn't you say that's, what do you
think? What else? No, I mean number one.
Number two,
I mean,
what else would people buy it be a
product that we don't know about?
I've seen a bunch of like similar
items. I mean, it's not rocket science.
Gang gets alone, something soft to shoot
loads into. It's not that complicated.
Vaseline,
something along those lines.
Anyway, go to Joe Rogan. Dot.
And then click on the link for the
fleshlight entering the code name, Rogan,
and you will get 15% off.
There you go.
And it comes in a brown paper thing.
You don't know what the fuck it is.
You don't have to feel it
barest. Hey, are you allowed to say
how much more do these runs? I thought,
I don't know how much they run. I
don't know. We get, we don't get,
we get 'em for free. I think it's
actually, it's less than 169 bucks.
I think I would say $100. Even at
when you're paying $100, she's,
you're filming like a creep.
Yeah.
No matter what.
It's a,
it's a stigma that unfortunately is
stuck in our head that masturbation is
somehow another evil and
paying for something,
buying something and then fucking
it. And that's, no, nobody's,
nobody's proud of that.
So it's going to be stigmatized
no matter what. Well, you know, as an
example, this just look at a price.
I think we should price it with,
go ahead. Tell him how much, uh,
before that beautiful
coupon code that you have,
you can get Susie diamonds,
vagina for $67 and 96 cents.
Now I don't know if the quality of
the girl changes for the flashlight.
Would you say like Jim and Jim
said different girls? I'm like,
if it was only as tight as
their actual vagina. Oh right.
I'm sure that's what they do cause
they mold is no one the inside.
It's got to be a standard core. I
think it's just the outside. Well,
each girl has a different texture inside.
I know that like Hayes,
you know she's got a swirl.
Special blood.
Steven now second guessing why you
should have come on this fucking podcast.
It wait until 10:00 PM this thing started.
There's this hot girl.
I've never seen her before,
but her name's Ariel on the fleshlight
sheet. She has her flashlight.
She is beautiful.
Do. There's a billion porno
stars now. There's no way.
They never stopped making them and they
never retire. There's no end there.
The rats on a sinking ship.
Anyway,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com
that is our other sponsor, o n n I t,
makers of shroom tech sport.
This is the quarter seps mushrooms
and beef 12 supplemented a,
I know so many people that are on to
that now and been raving about it.
It's great for people that are
like really into endurance work.
If you're doing crossfit class or
taking Jujitsu or something like that,
it's an excellent endurance supplement.
Uh,
if you're just hanging around like Brian,
there's no need for it.
Brian, no benefit. I've used
the shroom tech is any of it.
I feel like I don't want to fuck anything
up. You don't want it to like people,
I don't want people to think that I'm
the, you're on the roids right. And I,
um, there's another, let's
just leave that right there.
There's another troop technical,
the shroom tech immune.
And the way it's been explained to me
is this one is a really fascinating one
that's great for your immune
system because your immune
system anticipates that
this live organism is mushroom,
has been eaten by the body and for
whatever reason interprets it as a bug,
interprets it as a cold so it fires up
your immune system for attack that never
comes. So, uh,
it's a really interesting supplement
just for your immune system,
which in these terrible times of colds,
especially when you're traveling, right?
Brian pump up your immune system.
We're also a makers of new mood,
which is a five HTP.
And L tryptofan supplement that is a
serotonin booster gives you a nice little
boost, makes people feel
very happy. And uh, you know,
I have friends that are on the
five HTP and they were also taking
antidepressants and their doctors
told them literally Neil Brown,
his doctor told them to stop taking the
five HTP because it's basically like
you're taking two antidepressants. Isn't
that nuts? The doctor would tell you,
stop taking this nutritional supplement.
It's a supplement that's
available everywhere at
fucking Gnc, at cvs pharmacy.
It's available everywhere.
It's so you just buy it.
Stop taking that and get this crazy
prescription shit that rewires your dome.
Get this pill that lets you except your
mundane reality and not be depressed.
Sometimes you should be fucking depressed.
All right.
I know there's people out
there that are unbalanced,
but there's people out there depressed
simply because of the environment that
they exist. And on a daily basis, the
stimulation over and over against sucks.
And this pill's not going to help that
and just tell you right now you've got to
get your shit together.
Should we talked about last week,
by the way? I got an answer.
There was a contamination
in Japan. Wow. Wow. Back.
But that's not related to the
nuclear contamination. No, I didn't.
I don't think so. I think that's
carrying the fuck out of me. Yeah,
we've got to get to that. We'll talk to
that Steve. Or ready to live in the woods.
Do it. He's prepared. This is mother
fucker can survive out there. Um,
we also make Alpha brain at [inaudible]
dot com Alpha brain is the controversial
yet effective cognitive
enhancing supplement, as always,
with all on it products.
The number one concern is that you don't
feel like you're getting ripped off.
So here's how we make it as
easy as possible. First of all,
if you buy it and you don't like, it's
a hundred percent money back guarantee,
you don't even have to return the product.
If you buy it and you don't like it,
just tell us and you get your money back.
So that simple. And then on top of that,
I encourage you, first of all, before
you ever take any sort of a nootropic,
essentially vitamins and nutrients
that aid your brain function.
Just go Google it. Go. It's so
easy to do. It's free. Go Google.
Read all the different studies,
draw your own conclusions.
There's a bunch of different proprietary
blends other than ours that are
available. And I've tried a couple. If
I tried neuro one, I really liked that.
That set a football player.
What does that guy's name,
the big Roman [inaudible] I think.
I believe it's his,
cause he's a guy's a had some issues
with concussions and stuff like that.
So He created this, uh, this nutrient
rich stuff for your brain. Gay.
I encourage people to try that.
Try to steal our recipe by
the stuff in bulk and copy it.
I am way more concerned with you not
feeling ripped off then you buying any of
our shit.
But if you do want to buy our shit,
it's at [inaudible] dot com o n n I t
use the code named Rogan and you'll get
10% off. All right, that's it. Let's
get fucking crazy. Steve Ronell's here.
We're going to break shit down.
We're going to figure out how to eat
or on animals. My head's really now,
but all the supplements I
can be carried trying my day.
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Do you take any supplements or you just
out there and fucking eaten game every
day?
I really don't,
but you know,
I do cause I mean I drink coffee half
the day and then stop for a minute and
then at night I'll tend to have a few
drinks or a couple, you know, depending.
So I guess in all,
you know,
I'm constantly feeling that I'm feeling
this way and I wish I was feeling more
of that way. Like more awake
or more tired. Well the
coffee's not going to help,
boy, when you know it does
it. Cause I'd take that,
I'd take that and I take that for a nap.
This guy on Daniel Bolelli and he had
the smartest thing to say about coffee.
He said, I use it like a hard
drug. He goes, I don't take it.
But then when I have to take it when
I'm really tired and I needed like the
stamp to write a paper or something
and he was like, then I take it, boom.
I'm just wired,
whereas I got to a point where I could
drink a cup of coffee and just go to
sleep.
Oh, for sure. And you could
do that, right? Yeah. But it
wasn't like that at a time,
you know? Now it just seems like kind
of honestly, it seems like a hot,
smelly drink. No, I don't know. I'm always
like, for instance, before doing this,
I was like, I should go get a
cup of coffee. Yeah, me too.
I haven't looked for a Starbucks. If I
have access to it, I want it all the time.
If I'm out, like if we're on the field
and, or I'm camping or something,
I might make a little thing of instant
coffee in the morning and never think of
it the rest of the day. But it
just has to do with, I don't know,
man of force of habit. Yeah. I almost
hate it. I almost hate it about myself,
but no, I don't take as far as any
actual supplements go, I don't,
I tend to be a skeptic
about things that no, no,
I don't.
Hmm. Well, uh, I was a skeptic about
vitamins and supplements and start toy.
I looked into them and also I looked
into the fact that the government's been
trying to restrict him for a long time.
They were going to make them
available only through prescriptions.
Then we got to call them nutriceuticals.
It was some deal that they were with
pharmaceutical companies because
pharmaceutical company is going, so that
fucking money we can be making boys.
What's going on? Capitol Hill Hook us up.
We're getting you an office. What's up?
So they came up with this ridiculous
idea that they were gonna make vitamins
available.
Only imagine if you had to go to a
fucking doctor to get a multivitamin.
How pissed he would be. Like, it's
just nonsense. Just more regulations,
more big business. You fuck heads,
you get a prescription for carriers.
But there's a,
there's real science behind vitamins.
There's a real science
behind the, uh, the, the,
all the work that's been done to figure
out like, which vitamins enhance, which,
you know, what's good for vision, what's
good for muscular endurance. So, you know,
what gives you energy be 12. Why
is that? Let's find out. I mean,
there's supplements are real.
They're legit. You know,
B 12 is a fabulous energy supplement.
It's in everything. People take it.
I know people had taken shots.
They go to a place every week at
clinic and get a beat. 12 shot.
It's been 12 the one that only comes
through animal protein, animal protein,
but animal products in some way.
I do believe that's it.
I remember guys saying that lecture, let
me, let's, let's, let's find that out.
Because people would say,
people would say that you
can't be vegetarian because
be 12 I remember reading,
I think it was B 12 that you get
enough B12 from insect contamination.
Holy Shit.
On produce to stay alive.
Yeah. B12 only in animal foods.
President only in animal foods.
Like if you don't like wash every
single fold and a cabbage leaf,
you're going to get 12
yeah. I saw some fucking
crazy statistic online to the,
the pounds of bugs,
bug parts that a human being and living
in a city will eat over the course of
their life. It's mind boggling.
It's like several pounds like bag.
Oh Helen's of bug parts. If you eat out
of my garden at my house. I mean it's,
it's almost kind of ridiculous but I
don't even like eat around it so much
anymore. You know when I watched
your show, the wild with it,
I thought it was really interesting
that you live in the city,
you live in it like you were
living in Brooklyn, right.
And yet you were doing the show when
you're out in the fucking woods.
Like if you know how cool it is out there,
why would you want to live in
Brooklyn? I when, when I met,
it's oddly my first date with my wife
was a four day date here in Los Angeles.
At the time I was living in Alaska
and even when I asked her out,
I had to call her on a satellite
phone from the north slope of,
of the Brooks range where I was and
she was in New York and I asked her,
oh cause I had met her through work,
through book publishing.
So we started dating,
we had our four day date.
I went back to Alaska and I made a bet
there with a guy named Matt Carlson.
I said, I bet you a hundred
bucks, I'll marry that girl.
And he called bullshit on that
and I want to win the bet.
But I think that largely
just to win that bet, um,
to win that hunter barks,
you know,
I want up getting married
and moving in with my wife.
That was like a big part of
your motivation. Real. It
ain't no, no, no, I'm joking.
But yeah, so she, she works in book
publishing and we met that way.
I'm gone now maybe half the time,
but yeah, I spend half my time there.
MMM.
It's complete living there.
I grew up in Michigan and
lived in Montana for 10 years,
but living in New York has changed
everything. I thought I knew,
you know, and I realized in a big way. Um,
I tend to think kind of whatever,
everyone around me doesn't think.
So when I lived in Montana,
I attended,
I would find myself having views on things
that would skew leftward cause I was
responding to a strong, right. You
have like a natural contrarian.
So now being in New York has made me,
I'm a lot,
I'm kind of,
if you picture like an old
man who fought and you know,
World War Two and like yelled
at kids who come on his yard,
I'm kind of becoming like
that from being there.
It's had such a profound effect on me, you
know, cause I had, I not good. Right? No,
I like it. I enjoy it. I like you like
to come with that guy. You know what?
Because it's such a fresh perspective.
Every day I wake up and I
see the world in a new way.
I see it through the eyes of a mean old
man. Oh that's hilarious. So, but no,
we're there now and I
can't at all complaining.
It's the thing that people bring up most
off. Like how can you live there? Um,
I go out now and I still have great
friends and contacts and then you know,
wild places and we'd go and hang out and
do wild stuff and I'll pack up a cooler
full of whatever we've been chasing,
game meat.
And I go back to my house and I have
a very pleasant existence there.
We have a young boy, it's just fun
and it and it feels more like, um,
okay.
Kind of like emerge, you know, like,
like going out into the wild woolly
then like kind of coming back and
decompressing.
If I didn't,
if I wasn't involved in the line of work
where I would travel so much time and
get to see such great wilderness areas
and do such cool stuff, it would,
it would bother me more. But you can
buy travel so much. Yeah, it's just,
it's fun and cool. If I, if I
wasn't doing what I'm doing now,
I would probably have to, I would
probably have to split, you know,
I'd probably wouldn't be able to go there,
but in a way I'll always like
when I'm long gone from there,
I'll always look back at being in New
York as very educational because when you
look, I think all of
this all the time, like,
like grown where I grew up in semi-rural,
Michigan or live in places,
it's hard to drive down the road and
imagine all the things that drive like
global enterprise and global politics.
Cause you Kinda,
you can't really out who around me would
care enough about these things to make
these happen.
Like for instance,
like I can't drive down a road in
Michigan and be like, Oh that's why we're,
that's why we invaded Iraq. You know what
mean? It's like, right, you don't see,
you know where things are going.
But in New York you kind of go like,
oh that's why, that's that way. That's
why the movies that get made are,
that's why they get made or that's why
what's on TV is on TV or that's why the
books I read are the books I read cause
these are the people that you know are
doing all this and it gives,
it just like helps me more understand why
America kind of looks like American as
much as people
yeah.
In the U s tend to want to look at like,
like New York or la as being this
like weird otherness in a big way.
I just find that it's more,
it's more of an accurate portrayal of,
of culture than you'd ever think because
that's where so much culture is getting
produced. And I never really picked
up on this living in other places.
I don't know if I'm making any sense.
You're totally making sense. Brian. Is
there something wrong with this mic?
It keeps, it's like it dropped
off. Something happened.
It's just if you're really loud. Oh,
it's a got a regulator on it. Yeah.
You got some new crafty
technology going on here. No,
it's been on there for awhile.
You're making complete total
sense. Um, I, you know,
I always say that humanity is
what it is at its potential.
What is potential best or
potential worst and the,
what you see in New York is how,
I mean there's some,
there's a community to New York for sure.
You know,
there's definitely a closeness to
the people there and you, you really,
there was really
accentuated after nine 11.
I remember I went to New York really
shortly after nine 11 and everybody was
like really friendly and it was like
really a profound difference from the way
people were communicating
with each other when I,
when I lived there at one point in time.
And I think it's because just naturally
human beings are not designed to live
like that.
That is just an alien form of tribe.
That's ridiculous.
Did the amount of input that comes into
a person on a daily basis is way more
than the body is designed for and we're
just assuming that we can take it and it
shows time and time again.
All these fucking people died of heart
attacks when they're in their 50s no, no,
we're not taking it.
We're not taking it well at all.
This is not best case scenario for
the human body. It's very stimulating.
It's very crazy.
But all the behavior aspects of it,
all the problems,
all the things that people do wrong,
it's all been demonstrated in rat
population density studies. Yeah.
They've done those tasks where they have
a couple rats in a big pan and the rats
are cool with each other,
but he's fine.
And then they slowly jam him up until
the point where rats become crazy.
They're sitting in the corner, Buck and
back and forth. They kill other rats.
Chaos goes on.
I mean it's really what it is.
It's like either there's too much fucking
stimulation and there's not enough
resources, too much
stimulation, but there's not.
But I think beyond the stimulation,
so you don't have a lot of, uh,
okay.
Like I could probably handle a lot of
stimulation of my own choosing, you know,
but it was a lot of stimulation
that's not of your own choosing. So,
I mean you're being bombarded
by things like, like,
like if there was some way to like add up,
like if there's some way to
quantify stimulation and like units,
if I'm picking my subjects,
like I might pick a tremendous amount
in a given day. Like I'd be like,
I'd like to be bombarded
with this much stimulation,
but they're 90% of my capacity might be
filled by stuff that I didn't invite or
even want it.
It's just thrown at you.
It's to the point where I,
when I started hanging around there,
I did it very reluctantly. And at the
time I didn't even, I didn't have a home.
I have two brothers and one's in Montana,
ones in Alaska and they both,
when this is all going on, you
know, six, seven years ago,
whatever they were in that
situation where they had, you know,
they were making money, like they
were out of school and making money,
but they didn't have a wife to tell them
really how to spend it yet, you know,
so they had like nice houses that were
empty and I could just live in their
homes.
And so I live Tanner,
I live with my brothers and they thought
they were like patrons of the arts,
you know,
to have,
they have this writer brother and he's
sometimes lives in the basement or
sometimes he's off doing whatever he does.
And when I came to New York and started
being at my girlfriends and I would come
for a few weeks or
whatever amount of time,
we both recognize that something was wrong
for being there to the point where we
would say, Oh, if we get married, we
would of course move somewhere else.
And then it became, we got
married, they'd be like,
well once she's pregnant we would
of course move somewhere else.
And then she got pregnant and it's like,
well by the time the baby is
born we will of course split.
And now maybe by the time he's
five we're supposed to split.
He's a year and a half right now. But
it's like we know every day we wake up,
we're like, something isn't
like there's some thing that we,
there's some reason that this really
easy to stay very hard to leave really
cause of work. Man, she has like
a good job. I have, you know,
I'm busy with various projects.
It's really hard and when you see so much
of the country suffering and we should
tell everybody about your new show
before we even go to meet eater.
It's on when it's on Sundays,
9:00 PM on sportsman channel and you
can probably find it just by looking at
meat or in a search. That's the
best way to find shows. You know,
fucking find the sportsman channel.
What channel is that? Okay,
well somebody got the other channels
like I don't know what comedy central has
no idea what channels already be eight
and 13 but people really know ABC,
NBC, CBS. You'd be like, it's not
in three, right? Yeah, I remember,
I remember channel seven was ABC.
Yeah, I totally, that's all gone.
I don't know what any channel is.
I just look for the shows. No.
Yeah I have no idea.
I found out the PBS is 13 cause my boy
likes to watch a little Elmo now and then
and that's the only one I know by number.
But no, it's on sportsman channel.
Sunday nights, 9:00 PM.
Um, it's available widely
often to premium channel. Is it also
available on iTunes and stuff like that?
If people, it will be though
we've only been, you know,
we've only been Erin for three weeks,
but that episodes will eventually be
available across a variety of formats.
But right now that's where it is right
now on. I was a big fan of your show,
the wild within. I really enjoyed
that show man. That was great.
I loved the one when you,
uh,
when across the country and like tried
to live like Lewis and Clark and shot a
buffalo with a musket and shit. Like the
whole deal. I was like, wow. Like this is,
this is a fun show.
Bombed out has been huge into um,
I've always been huge into that Lewis
and Clark idea and in that one to nutty
fucking idea, man. Dude. But the thing,
here's the thing I dig about Lewis and
Clark and you'll, you'll appreciate this.
We were just talking about New York
so much, but like Lewis and Clark,
so early 18 hundreds you know,
they split out of Saint Louis and they
go over the two year journey, you know,
go all the way to the Pacific and come
back and there's places along that route
there. Now of course towns, you know, and
I've lived in a number of, in Bozeman,
Montana,
Missoula,
Montana where they wandered through and
now it just looks like a town and people
live there. There's a lot of
places they went, for instance,
this place called the Missouri breaks
where nothing ever happened there again,
you know, and you can go to New York
and in some of them might be like, oh,
you know what right here,
like John Lennon got shot right here.
It doesn't feel like Andy because so many
other layers of things have happened.
You know what I mean?
Like other people died there and
people got arrested there and you know,
people built houses there and tore up
the sidewalk and made a new sidewalk and
it winds up being an after awhile.
It becomes,
it's worse than being buried by years.
It's just been buried
by layers of experience.
But we're floating on a Missouri breaks.
When I,
before I even thought of
the idea to do that episode,
were flown on a Missouri breaks and
I was with a writer friend of mine.
I was kind of a mentor of mine,
he and Frazier and we're laying there
in the spot where we knew they can't
because it's in her journals.
They described these camp
spots. He's like, no one,
like basically they were here and then
a couple hundred years went by and now
we're here and you can see it. You just
look at the ground and it'd be like,
you might find like one of their tools,
someone, yeah. Something was like,
it's possible to feel history in a,
in a more immediate way. And that's
not even old history. I mean,
you imagine like there's bars in England.
Yeah.
If it had been open continuously longer
than it's been since Lewis apart went
out west. So everything like in, in,
in, in the western US old is not old.
Old as only Olin comparison.
Yeah. Yeah. Only old relative,
but that's why I always did that stuff.
And I've always had a
real penchant for like,
like just going to archaeological
sites where maybe it's just a lack of
imagination.
But if I can look and there's still some
little stone shards laying underground,
I'm like, this I can
relate to. If you, you,
I'm sure you've found arrowheads and shit,
that's pretty cool. I found a number,
arrowheads,
but the problem is getting into arrowheads
is you get into a level of kind of
sewer ship where the
only really cool stuff,
it's like the ice age stuff
like Folsom, Clovis. Uh,
so now like once I started
getting into seeing him,
I got in my mind that the
real one would be this.
And so now I'm perpetually
dissatisfied because you don't find,
I found the arrowhead. I'm African. You
have to find them yourself. Correct.
It's not, it doesn't mean shit. If you
go buy one on Ebay and you know it's,
you know what buying them on Ebay is
almost better than when the dude next to
you find someone.
We're just filming.
We were filming a meat eater episode
in Arizona and I'm down on my hands and
knees scouring in outside this cave
entrance for stone charts and we had,
just for the moment we had this double,
a kid that works on this ranch came out
and see what was going on and he's kind
of like wondering why I'm doing this.
And he's like,
well here's the arrowhead right there.
And it was the only Arrow had we found
and he just picked that thing up.
I'm kind of cursing it.
I find chunks, you know,
and we call them shards or if you
want to get even more technical,
they call him a lithic remains
or something like that.
This little bits of stone,
you wouldn't even know if he saw it.
But to me it's like I have a
pile of Matt home basically.
It'd be like if you're whittling a stick,
I find the little chunks,
the flight and I never
find the sharp stared.
And how do you know that
that's how they're created.
It wasn't just like something falling on
something and there's a thing called a
can coital fracture.
I may be pronouncing it first.
And that's how they create the Ed.
Yeah.
It winds up being that it just doesn't
get replicated from two rocks banging
together. Freezing. Does it replicate it?
It's like a pressure flake
[inaudible] tool stone.
Like we always say like arrowheads are
made out of Flint, like Chert, Flint,
obsidian, personal night,
all these different things.
Fracture in a specific way when slow
pressures applied to them and you'll look
and there'll be like a this dome
shape thing on it and it, it's,
it's considered to be,
it's technically diagnostic.
Like you can look at it and you would
be able to say like in the peer reviewed
scientific journal that that is a human
worked stone. Oh, okay. You know, it's,
it's that obvious. I get eight has to be
replicated by repetitive yeah. Shipping.
And they look at it like you'll,
you'll look at it. It's not like, oh,
I think that was, no,
that was uh, you know,
that was a fractured stolen by how long
ago did they first start doing that?
Like, how long did people just shoot
arrows at shit? You know, like when, well,
when was the first bone Arrow?
Do you know?
They say the Bono was invented many times.
Not many times.
I could be wrong,
I'm just,
but the bone marrow may have been invented
six or seven or more times. Really?
No humans first arrived in North America
through Siberia in the Bering land
bridge, maybe, you know,
with big foot maybe 13, 14,
15,000 years ago. Somewhere in
there. It's like, it's hotly debated,
let's say 14,000 years ago
when they arrived here,
they were making very intricate stone
points that were more ornate and technical
and beautiful than things that were
being made thousands of year later.
But they didn't have the bow. There's been
more human. His, they were just spears.
Yeah, probably like, uh,
they think that what was in use most
widely may have been an adult ladol like a
throwing board. Okay, so a spear with
like a thing that you throw it with. Yeah,
it'd be based,
it's like an extension of your arm.
So it'd be like a board that you can
get more leverage that you see people at
the park throwing for a dog,
like throwing a tennis ball for a dog.
Imagine a contraption like that
that helped you throw a spear. Yeah,
I think I've seen those and
they were, well, you know,
it's the old hippie thing like
old hippie guys, you know,
the kind of like old hippie guy
who would go out, for instance,
he may be like has an old Hippie van
and he likes to nap arrowheads in, in,
in uh, has a lot of feathers and
rocks and stuff on his dashboard.
Those guys would get into adult adults.
Right. I see what you're saying. Now, all,
all ad level guys are not old hippies but,
but it's uh, it's an old hippie thing.
It's not very well known that the same
way playing disc golf, right? Frisbee,
golf or whatever,
where they call that Frisbee Golf.
Like a certain dude plays Frisbee Golf,
but not all guys that play Frisbee
golf or those kinds of dudes.
Certain guys play with atlatls.
Yeah.
There's certain people that look
at Frisbee evolve and they just go,
what the fuck man, I'm not doing that.
Yeah, exactly. It's not really my thing.
And so there is more human history
in North America pre then post bone.
So maybe the bone Arrow made the
scene around this for 5,000 years ago.
So the really all throughout the world,
no, no, no, no Justin, I'm north places.
Different Times.
So North American amendment four or five
vans invented or did someone introduce
it or is that not known? It
would have been, and again,
when you start talking about this stuff,
it's,
it's like very informed guesswork,
right?
If the people that arrived here that
migrated into the western hemisphere,
my migrated in North America,
they arrived here without it
and it emerged much later.
You'd have to think did
it emerged independently.
People came here without it
and it developed and they
say, and like I said, I've,
I don't know this for sure,
by red at times that they think the boat
emerged six or seven different times.
Like certain things just get
invented again and again.
And I often like try to think when I
tried to think of whether something's
normal or abnormal or right or
not. Right. I imagine that if you
backed up human history to the beginning,
so let's say you backed it up to like
the African diaspora when when humans
first left Africa to populate the world,
if you backed it up and had
everybody do it all over again,
would it happen again?
And I'm like,
wearing your pants down around
your hips will not happen again.
You don't think so? No. It wouldn't
happen again. Hunting and fishing,
what happened again? For sure.
Yeah. Do you know what I'm saying?
But certain aspects of culture
you'd think? Yeah, like
writing books. I don't know.
Maybe it was like, uh, maybe it wouldn't
happen again. You know, singing songs.
I bet you seeking something
would have happened again. Singing songs
wouldn't know it would have happened to.
Definitely. Definitely. As
with jokes, jokes would be
written. They would, it would,
it would happen. All happen
everywhere. In every culture.
I think people are going to record
keeping, but yeah, you're right.
Like look at the different branches
that civilization has taken.
If you just pay attention to the world,
like you know you've got to,
I just got back from Brazil, you
know, you're different cultures.
That's a totally different branch of how,
how you can live or go on and went off
on their own trip and then their own trip
happens to be in South America.
Our own trip is up here in North America.
I mean it's like you know,
you have to change it based
on your environment and how
much you have to protect
yourself from the environment as well.
You know that's a lot of how their
behavior is based but it's a,
it's amazing how many variables there
are when you think about it. Yeah.
Now that you bring up South America,
I will tell you another trippy thing.
I don't,
I don't want to like drag design with the,
with like human migrations up
am I was in or interesting.
I'm interested like through the lens like
cause I like the hunt through the lens
of honey.
I'm interested in early hunters because
these guys hunted all the time and for
their life. That's, listen, this is a,
there's a life and death struggle to that,
that you know,
we in this first world where you just
go to the supermarket and get your food,
whether you're immediately
or not, I mean the, the,
the lack of understanding and appreciation
of hunting and gathering and that
it's literally a part of being a
human being. Maybe not hunting.
If you really become a
vegetarian and you're,
you're just gung Ho for
that for whatever reason,
you're allowed your own thoughts.
I don't mind, I don't care.
I don't want to change
anybody's opinion on it,
but you're just making
your own vegetable garden,
growing your own food and eating it and
for surviving off some stuff that you
have actually grown yourself.
You have this like really intimate
relationship with your food then,
which I think is a part of being an
intelligent thing that is aware of its
environment.
I think one of the issues that human
beings have as a whole is that in order to
feed us all,
in order to move us all in the general
direction that we move in and to do it in
big cities that live on the waters,
you're going to have a lot of waste.
You don't have pollution, you're
going to have pro. It's just going to,
it's not going to be done clean and tidy.
It's going to be done wild and chaotic,
you know,
and a lot of it is because we are not
feeling the damage that we're doing.
It's not like we are, you know, shitting
in our own backyard and going, man,
maybe you should stop shitting in the
backyard. This is ruining the whole place.
No, it's happening somewhere that's
not even anywhere near your house.
And as long as you can
get your cheeseburger, you
don't give a fuck. You know,
as long as you can pull into that drive
through and then an ass friend number
two large and just, you know, give him
some paper and then you've got your food.
It's that easy. That lack of connection
when you're still a carnival,
when you still an animal,
you'll still a biological entity that's
processing other biological entities and
plants and you know, I mean
you're, you're, you have to,
you're living off living things period.
Everybody is with your fucking vegetarian
and not man, but we don't feel that.
We don't feel that because,
because we have completely distanced
ourselves from the gathering and the
growing and all that.
We're like little children so we just
shit all over the floor and that's,
that's literally
and not men.
My opinion,
one of the number one things
that's wrong with human culture,
we've grown too fast for our biology
I think. I think that's a valid point.
And I would say, I hate to
hammer it home and say like, Oh,
you're not a complete person if you
don't have the experience of putting your
own food or growing your own food.
I don't want to be extreme like that,
but I'll say it like there's this whole
suite of human activities that seem to
help you develop and do a fuller
person as does like pairing,
eating like reading is helpful
for your world perspective.
I think that some amount of travel is
helpful for your world perspective.
I think that doing some,
some hunting or or some sort of food
gathering is helpful for your world
perspective. Not even say we were
talking about earlier New York earlier,
I started a garden. We have a lot, we
have a 800 square foot garden in New York,
which is a rarity and then
I beat this garden into the,
into the weeds and detritus that was in
that backyard and I later had the soil
tested and had very high elevated
levels of lead and I've been trying to
mitigate that over the years
and get it under control
from pollution from let
it get what they want.
When I set my stuff off to Cornell to
have it tested and the paperwork they gave
me said that people have a
tendency to blame led paint,
but of it was from just leaded gasoline
that there was that much exhaust over
those years of lead gasoline that just
led to settle and assist near the surface.
I remember when people were mad that
they got rid of letting remember it.
I remember like I remember
like I graduated high school
in 1992 I remember dudes
have an old time old cars and they would
have to buy led additive and added into
old cars. They couldn't get knighted
gas anymore, you know? Yeah. I remember.
It seems like so long ago now. It's crazy,
but I'm thinking about it, but yeah,
that awareness all of a sudden about loud,
are you replacing this?
So know there's a number
things they tell you to do. A
lower on the Ph scales lower,
high,
low as acidic, right? I
don't know. Seven is neutral.
Six is slightly acidic.
They tell you to raise the Ph.
They tell you to introduce a lot of
organic matter and that will inhibit the
plant's ability to pickup led and
they tell you to not plant, um,
things like potatoes and things
where there might be actual physical
contamination of dirt that the
fear is it you're just eating dirt.
It's not that the plants uptake,
I mean the plant can't uptake led at some,
at some amount under some conditions,
but mainly they don't want you
eating the dirt. So it's spinach,
which has a lot of folds.
We're talking about insect contamination,
knew there the same plants that would
have a tendency to like hold insect eggs
and you don't wash them out properly.
They tried to get you to not grow that.
So the ideal plant for leaded
soil would be like leather.
You grew a tomato for instance. It's way
off the ground. It's very easy to clean.
But dealing with that little battle,
you know,
just for the simple desire like grow food,
made me more aware of,
uh,
of the complications of having
some level of an urban life.
You know, it's like there's,
it's in your mind like, oh,
of course the city must be polluted.
It's a city.
But then to go out and see it in your
yard and like battle it and have it put to
you in numbers,
you know,
like you have blank parts per million
lead really woke me up to that level and
also kind of infuriated me
in an environmental way to
think that it seems like
some kind of like God given,
right,
that if you've got dirt you should be
able to grow plants on it and imagine that
we're at a point where you're
growing plants out of the dirt for,
you know, the, this like you're
advised against eating to me, you know,
it was just kind of like upsetting.
It's upsetting to me. And again,
it's like process that like weird lack
of imagination where until something's
really brought home to me really clearly.
It doesn't make as much sense to me.
I used to be not like, I used to
tend to be not very sensitive, um,
about deforestation or about development.
And it was only until now when I go and
visit where I grew up in all the woods I
that I hung out in,
you know,
and I could leave my home and wander
for miles and some directions.
It just had to cross a road on them,
but always be in the woods.
It's all built up. It's
all built up now. Wow.
And so now I could have heard about it
happening to a hundred other guys and it
wouldn't have bothered me, but to go to
my spots where I hung out and be like,
yeah, I couldn't go where I used to hang
out without crossing 20 people's yards.
And getting hollered at all of a
sudden makes me be like, you know what?
We need to really check out
what we have for wildlife habitat and
what we have for like places to hang out
in what we have that
hasn't been destroyed yet.
And be maybe a little more conservative
with it and a little more like
parsimonious.
And it's always those little awakenings
that I get only on a personal level, man.
You know?
Well,
I think we all experience information
that way because if we didn't,
there's so much that we're
getting every day on CNN. I mean,
imagine if he took every
God damn story to heart.
Like who was your own house
that was getting foreclosed on,
or your own kid that was kidnapped or
your own friend that was shot or you know,
you know your own house, but there's
too much. It's too much information.
So you see, oh, 10 people died
in Iraq today. You're like, wow,
I guess that really sucks man. You
know, I feel bad for the family.
You're not even really personifying.
You almost said it down to
remind yourself at some news.
You got to sit down and like take a
moment and remind yourself to feel the
emotion of it. Yeah. I find myself
doing that all the time. Like, wow,
you should really feel this should be,
they should have like a sense of
gravity to you. And, and I'd be like,
now I will take a moment and allow
myself to feel what I should feel.
But you know,
but maybe I'm too busy to feel.
Yeah. I, I've, I've heard like when people
talk about the miles of the rain forest,
that gets chewed up every year
and those numbers are the,
it's a staggering number. It's a
terrifying number. Just miles and miles.
A rain forest that gets
eaten up and it really,
I can't, doesn't register. I
can't, I can't register it.
I know it's bad. It's bad.
It's terrible. But am I
feeling it? I'm not feeling it.
I don't know why I'm not feeling it.
I'm, I'm a concerned person. If you ha,
if you said, hey, you can make the call,
should they be allowed to chop down those
trees? I'd say no. Stop right there.
The rain forest is amazing,
but
still it doesn't matter you, you
unless you see it, unless you're there,
unless it's like a part of
your life, you know. I don't,
I don't think you're going to, it's, we
flew over the rain forest because we,
we went to Brazil this past weekend and
it was day time while we're flying and I
was looking down and I'm like,
wow, that is fucking nuts.
Yeah, it's, it's I, the first time
I flew over like the Amazon area,
you grew up with one
impression of wilderness.
Like if you grow up with an American
impression of wilderness and we have,
we're very fortunate in our resources.
I mean if you look at how much money we
make and how many people live here and
when we've done a pretty phenomenal job
preserving some places to fly over like
the northern half of South
America. Yeah. Is so fucking crazy.
I mean like, like I always
look at everything like this,
kind of like hunter angle and I looked
down there and I'd like to know that
there are people down there
who've had very limited,
perhaps no experience with the outside
world because then that's used to seem to
me like that can't be true.
Did you fly down there and you realize
that you've just flown four hours and
there's been nothing, no road,
no anything. You're like,
oh, now it makes sense. Yeah.
For guys live around the rain forest
while you're going 500 miles an hour,
you're like, a guy could live
down there and you would never,
you would never know.
Yeah. It's amazing. You know,
they said that the most recent
uncontacted tribe there,
these photos of them and video,
it's actually a hoax like somebody had,
they had fucking fake.
Yeah. You know, I know I heard what
you're talking about, the starving,
but it was for a while they thought they
advantaged, like people that were red.
They were,
they weren't.
Yeah. Red. Yeah. There's still
on I and not uncontacted tribes,
but tribes that have had very, very
limited contact with the outside world,
and it's just because
the actual volume of it,
but it's an amazing that
there's environments where
people live that they really
just got to a certain point, they said,
listen, fuck electronics and everything.
Like it rains every day.
That shit's not gonna work.
We're never going to develop any of that.
We just need to be really
good with bows and arrows,
and there's plenty of food
here. It's just stop. I mean,
and there's a lot of people that admire
that and they look at that like, wow,
there's something magical about
the way these people live.
Like I have friends that have gone to
a different parts of South America for
IOWASCA rituals.
You know,
you're talking about tools and you'll
stay in these, uh, these camps, these,
you know, these, these towns,
these villages I guess with these people
and these straw houses and you'll stay
with them for like a week.
And one of my buddies went and was like,
the crazy thing is like at first you see,
you kind of feel bad for them,
but then when you're leaving you kind of
feel bad for yourself. He's like, fuck,
I got to deal with bills and all this
bullshit that the weather is always
perfect here. When it rains
they get inside. Yeah.
I mean it's like they're like living in
paradise and they're pulling fish out of
the river on a regular basis. Shooting
animals. The animals are everywhere.
Stick together, look out for Jaguars
were good. And you're like, man, who,
if it is a temporary experience
and it absolutely is. I mean,
no one gets out of this alive who sues,
doing it the right way.
They look like they're having fun.
Yeah. I think too that it
doesn't need to be like for, for,
for ancestral hunter gatherers or
people who are hanging out on land that
they've probably been on for
10 generations, you know,
20 to infinity generations. Right. It
doesn't need to be an all or nothing.
Like I had the experience last
winter. Um, so hunt with some guys in,
in Guyana dam and they have
some access to internet.
You know, they have like DVDs
laying around their place.
They have a generator that gives them
electricity some amount of time during the
day. Um, they had never heard of pizza.
One of them had a t shirt with Muhammad
Ali on it. I asked them who that was.
He, he didn't know who
that was. So there's some,
like they've had the t shirt
but they don't know who's on it.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Right there. Kinda like half,
like a foot into the modern world
and a foot out. But just due to the,
to where they live.
And due to financial constraints,
they provide all their own food.
So they raised their own food and these
guys hunt 200 250 days a year if they
don't have on it. Cause they
got something today before they,
they're a hundred fish every
day so well because they're not,
they don't have enough
refrigerators to keep things.
They don't bring it and it'd be too far
to bring it to be too expensive to bring
it and they have like
ready access to stuff.
So it would be that you to think that
right now it's almost kind of an inspiring
thought to think that
right now there are people,
I'll name one guy was guy
named Rovan who wakes up,
he's able to wake up and check his email
and he's obligated that day to go hunt
something for his family to
eat for dinner. It's like the,
that these two things can
still exist side by side. Wow.
It's Kinda my binding because he can get
a computer but he just can't get food,
you know. And this guy has a remote garden
area and his whole family will take,
dug out canoes to the garden area and
check on the garden and harvest what they
have and tend to everything.
Then they go back to their hunting camp
and like turn on various things they've
gotten through government grants
and things and like in log on and,
and see if you want to be his friend
on Facebook. I'm not joking. It is.
So it's so bizarre, you know, and just
kind of tell that guy, that guy's a dress.
I want to be his friend on Facebook.
Oh, doodle have you over there.
And they got like a,
you know,
he's got like a couple Puranas hanging
up and he's making dinner. Wow.
So now what did you guys hunt for
when you went there? We hunted, um,
a number of large fish that
the, hang on here, the servers,
they have one. And when I say hunted,
they fished primary with bows and arrows.
So they're shooting fish. The one called
a [inaudible] one called Airwatch.
This was on your show?
Yeah. Yeah, we do. Yeah,
we do have down here the dude was like
really good at judging the reflect
refraction. Is that what it is to fix your
feet when you're looking at the water?
It's hard to see where the fish really is.
There's like a little,
he's not where you have to aim way low.
So if you're,
imagine that you're standing on the bank
of a lake looking into lake and there
was a fish who's maybe 24
inches below the surface,
mmm.
You would be aiming?
Yeah,
you'd be aiming a couple, let's say
he's like, he's 10 feet from the bank,
24 inches below the surface.
You'd be aiming at what would appear
to be about three feet below that fish.
So if you're looking at them from a
standing position and there are any thing
other than directly underneath you,
there's an optical illusion.
Is that what it is? Yeah, you got to
aim low. But where they're hunting,
they're hung in the river.
So when I was growing up,
we would shoot a lot of carp
with bows in still water,
um, in, in very fast modern bowls
with really heavy fiberglass arrows.
Which don't they keep their velocity
when it hit the water pretty good.
They're fast. These guys are shooting
an arrow. It's actually boiling it,
their Arrow floats.
So the Arrow really slows down when it
hits the water and they're shooting fish
in moving water.
So not only are you judging refraction
light refraction your where you know you
have to aim low,
you also have to aim way upstream.
And the arrows are affected in a very
profound way by all aspects of the water.
Like the Arrow comes to a stop.
It drifts into current.
Very good cause it's buoyant.
So if you're like,
you might find yourself aiming at a,
there's this herbivorous Parana there.
It's like a favorite fish.
That's the pocket. Yeah.
You might be holding try.
The fish is moving for one thing.
So the fish is on the move and you're
holding maybe what looks to be three feet
below it and two feet out ahead of it.
So that's where you're aiming as it's
moving because you need to figure that
that Arrow is going to drift down current.
Wow. Before it makes contact with fish.
That's like playing online video
games with a shitty connection.
If you've got 50,
exactly six k connection number.
That I wonder what happened when you play,
when you play certain games,
you'd have to leave the guy, you remember
that Brian, when you had lag, you know,
so you'd, you'd have probably
been really good at this.
Haven't had those experiences. But I shot
at though I shot it, that kind of fish.
MMM.
Around 25 times four. I hit one. Wow.
Over the course of several days. Wow.
So it was more than one day
before you hit one. Oh yeah, man.
So like I think I finally killed one
on my third day and we would only go at
optimum light when you have a good
high sun, like saying like, like,
like I like to fish with a fly rod for
bone fish and stuff and just is basically
good, you know, from 10 to
two, like the lights right
to, to, to see into the water.
Another thing we did was we hunted birds,
um,
with bows and I brought
down a, uh, a compound bow,
like a modern boat.
And they in those guys call it,
some of those guys speak English.
They've been trained to speak English in
order to navigate in a modern world and
with tourism and political issues because
their national language is English,
even though they're Macusa and
they speak a tribal language.
Indigenously but so you could speak some
English with them and they would call
my bowl the fancy bow, you know? And um,
they were blown away by the
bow and I felt kind of like,
at times I thought about leaving my
bowl there, but I thought I'd be like,
remember that God's must be crazy.
Like that coke bottle flies out of that
thing and like totally changes those
people's lives. I was like, if I
left these dudes with this bow,
the jungle be gone, man. It'd
be emptied of animals, you know,
they would like get everything there so
they'd have to make get arrows though.
How many hours did you have? That's true.
They would venture run out of arrows.
Arrows are you gonna make aluminum
arrows. And I would a jungle. These guys,
what was funny too is um,
you know,
have all these crazy plants that
they make their bowls narrows.
The only thing they need to make their
bow and Arrow is they use a piece of hog
fence, like a piece of wire fence and
they use that to make part of the head.
But I was saying like, what's that
plant you make the arrows out of?
He thinks about, he's
like aero plan, you know,
and then they got a plant today they
called the Arrow plants and it's supposed
to be straight like straight,
straight, straight, like a laser man.
And then they make,
they pull these leaves to make string.
They go out and harvest uh,
Robert from a rubber
tree to coat to string,
like to wax a string. Wow.
Then they get feathers.
Like we went out and killed a bird.
I with my compound bow,
I shot a bird down out of a tree
that they eat the Chrysalis curse.
So there's like how many, um, if you say
there was a hundred species of birds,
what, what percentage of them
do you think they eat? The main,
well are there certain brands you
just can't eat? They're just no good.
Most birds they would just,
it wasn't a day disregard them.
They would like observe
them and discuss them.
But it wasn't on their radar as a
food bird as a flavor or is it a,
I think it would probably wind up being,
if I had to guess bird flesh.
You'll find that like birds
tend to taste pretty similar.
You know there's not like bad tasting
birds and you know it winds up being like
a yield issue. So some of the
birds or after would be that
there's a strong likelihood that you're
not going to get your Arrow or the Arrow
will be damaged. So you're weighing
like what does my Arrow worth?
And there's these birds they like,
like crustless Curacao,
black Curacao would be something
equivalent to a Turkey. Okay.
This, they still one of those
and they would call them Po.
There were poets or something.
They would say when they see
him they see one of those.
Everybody get excited because it was
just worthwhile. Like in a caloric sense,
it was worth effort to try
to get the current style.
And the other thing about the black
Chris, I was a black curse. I was what?
They use a Fletcher arrows for the,
for the feathers on the arrows.
So when I shot a curse out,
we went out at three in the morning
pitch black to sneak up underneath where
Curacao was hooting up in this tree and I,
and I shot the down and he was really
happy that I shot that bird down one for
eating.
But two because he would make,
he told me he would make a year's worth
of arrows off the feathers off that
Corsol.
Wow.
So how do they attach the
feathers to the shafts they use?
They'd take the on a feather, what
do you call like the, like the part,
they'd be like equivalent to hair.
You have the vein and then you know,
the other part they would clean a little
bit off each end and they would just
tie it in two places.
Just wrap it in two places.
So like imagine my finger being
that they would wrap it on one end,
then he'd wrapped on the other end
and an aide caught a knock in there.
And real simple. Yeah. And then
they would, then they would have,
they would attach the arrowhead,
they would make a steel arrowhead
out a piece of fence wire,
but it would be socketed so it
would fit like a male female joint.
How did they do that? Because
they would bend it. They would,
they would peanut over with a
hammer on a rock fence wire. Yeah,
they would beat it until it was flat,
like aluminum foil thicker than aluminum
foil. And then they could curl it.
So it'd be like a piece of fence where,
and you imagine is banging on a,
imagine a pencil sized piece of wire and
you bang on that thing until you have a
thing on the end of it. This is about
the size of a 50 cent piece of just flat,
thin,
malleable metal steel.
You can then shape that into
whatever shape you want.
They would shape that into uh, like a, uh,
a socket it end that would shape it into
like a cop and that cop would fit over
the tip of the end of the stick.
That's the end of the Arrow.
What did they do before there was fence
wire or four people came along where
they could cut their wires, a stone and
bone, they would use stone and bone.
And so there's a fairly
recent thing. Yeah, I mean
fairly read, I mean metal age,
but you know like even like precontact
you know, like many of the track here,
you know,
in,
in our portion of the hemisphere in
North America precontact there's people
using copper know, like we're like
we're, I'm from native Americans.
They were already had copper
technologies put together. So it's not,
you could hardly argue that it's a modern
technology to take metal and hammering.
I'm kind of malleable
metal and hammered out.
However it is very modern technology to
cut it off a piece of fence, you know.
So they would do that and that would
be the one that'd be the one main,
main part.
And here's the thing is this isn't
like those guys being cute like early,
we're talking to like old hippies who
like to make addle. Addles this is guys,
these are the pragmatic people,
you know, trying to stay alive,
like making equipment. Um, but
beyond that they took to it,
uh, certain flourish. Uh,
each guy might have some little thing
he would do to make his special ed.
He would wrap a black that he'd like do
black thread and then he wouldn't put
the rubber on some of his thread and do
like a little bit of and then do some
more black and he wrapping it up so that
it would be like as little signature
style. Um, so it was a very pragmatic
device. They're hunting kit,
but along with it would become some amount
of ornamentation or personalization.
The same way. You know, you
buy a car and I put a van,
he played out under change rooms. Like
you're like, this is mine. You know,
like you look at this and you know,
it's mine.
And they would have little
things like that they did,
but that ornamentation wouldn't really
extend to like to their physicallness
like they would largely where you know
when you picture that people bring
clothes and donate old tee shirts and
someone puts them in a barrel and sends
them off.
I mean they would just be
dressed in American throwaways,
like maybe sweat pants cut off and a tee
shirt that might say Lord knows what I
mean. Anything on it. And they
would always, always barefoot.
How long did you spend with these people?
Spent two weeks with him. Wow. Yeah.
Just living like they live. Yeah, we ate
everything man. We ate just tons of stuff,
you know, get sick at all. Never
know. You know what? I know.
I don't know how cause I usually get sick.
I just spent four days in
the hospital from being sick.
Did four days in the hospital from
like a water for water? No waterborne,
waterborne, waterborne ailments and
Ted Yardi or you cola or something.
I had been this kind of
funny story because we had,
we were filming a meat episode in Northern
California and I got into a killed a
wild pig and wild pigs role and
poison oak. They like to roll in it.
I had heard of this place for foreign,
killed a pig and came home and had poison
oak. And so this time when I went out,
I just really watched for poise, not
make sure I didn't get any poison, don't,
but then kill this pig.
And the next day I'm,
I have sleeves of infection,
I'm arms and I had apparently did a
groin will scratch and that was all,
you know, how does Steve,
oh, not get any of this.
Remember we were talking to him about
drinking like jungle water. But yeah,
he's a fucking drinks,
drinks,
tap water everywhere he goes over
the world for his immune system. No,
I believe it. Well, I
mean, think about it man.
Like when you get a dog
and you get a new puppy,
now he's going to get GRD a couple of
times and he never did. Gets it again.
You build a tolerance to it, but so this
is a story starts to make its own gravy.
I realize it's kind of a long story,
but I got the poison oak so bad they
put me on prednisone. Wow. It's a wow.
It's so pregnazone can
compromise your immune system.
We then were we,
we were in Arizona filming and we were
hunting Cuzdey are down there and ran out
of water, a whitetail subspecies
called coups dear. Oh,
so who's is slang for vagina? Is
it really? He didn't know that. No.
I know some variations of that but not
that word. Coups. Brian boy, her son.
I accrues once a month but I never,
I never knew trolling was
trolling was for gay guys either.
Cause I tell people in Ohio I'm trolling
and they like all wink at me and starts
really trolling for gay guys.
For Northern Pike. Yeah.
Trolling online,
like you know,
trying to get people to pay attention
to a ridiculous story for his own
amusement. That's called online
trolling, trolling, trolling for fishing.
That is what a trawling as well.
But it's also, it's probably,
that's probably the dawn of it. Well, she
didn't steal it from online people. Yeah,
no, absolutely not. The online people,
I think they created a trolling because
it's sort of like they got a little
lower. Let's see who bites.
Let's see. Let's see.
He's with dummy argues with someone
who doesn't really believe what they're
saying, what they're only
saying things to be ridiculous.
I used to think it was cute,
but now I find it tiresome.
There's not enough time in the
world. So you get sick. Yeah, I'm,
the button is off and I had drank,
drank water out of this canyon and
sometimes the treat water with iodine
tablets, but the key with iodine
is you've got to let it sit.
So he did this for the show or you
did this because you were just,
when we were filming show
and ran out of water,
but we weren't like drinking creek water
as content because when we're doing
stuff we like really,
you know,
we really will walk along ways and run
out of stuff and eat some food out or eat
meat out or bought her out in the
process of making our shelves.
So we just got in a situation where we
had no water, went down into a canyon,
found some water and I was very thirsty
and I put my iodine tablets in my bottle
and,
and didn't let them dissolve.
I mean I waited for the
water to turn a little brown,
but the tablets are still fine in a,
in a drank the water.
A couple of other guys drank the water
and they both brought up with like a mild
case of the shits later.
But because I had the pregnazone
thing is what I like to blame,
I came down full. Was it the really
serious colon infection? Whoa.
In wound up. Yeah man. I wound up in the
hospital for four days. Holy Shit. Yeah,
that's terrifying.
That weighed that I lost so much.
I don't think I've weighed that amount
since I was 14 I lost so much weight. Wow.
I'd imagine. And like dude,
if you lose weight, I know.
I keep thinking like we were joking about
that like selling where you send that
if you get FDA approval.
Yeah,
just send water from that Right
Canyon to people as a diet plan.
Alpha Puke isn't that ridiculous that
people are so God damn week that you have
to give them some sort of a pathogen,
some sort of a horrible disease in order
for them to have an excuse to not eat
like a fucking pig. Now it is. But this,
I mean this is not,
I mean this knocked me back in a big
way and really it was kind of the first
moment when I really
started to feeling my years.
Like now I feel like a much older man
cause I had never been in a hospital
except for the day I was born.
I would imagine it's very
taxing on your immune system.
Has something like that happen.
I mean it must be just devastating.
I was beat up man.
I felt like a like a week old man.
I know prednisone can really fuck you up.
I have a friend who has sarcoidosis and
that's one of the things they gave him.
They gave him prednisone. I don't
even know what that is. What is that?
Some sort of a lung disease early
and I'm not exactly sure what it is,
but it was, it was, it fucked
him up bad. He gained a lot of water. He
was, we call the time and just really,
really didn't enjoy it at all. You could
really tell. The other thing about,
you know when he loses a lot of weight,
people can goof on you but they can't
goof on you and you gain a lot of weight.
So if you lose tons of weight, you'll
walk in the room. People be like,
you look like shit. Yeah, you look
like Shit, you lost so much weight.
But if you come in with the gut, they
can't say anything. No. People are going,
you look like shit. You're really fat.
You can't say that to people, man.
You live in a strange world.
You live in a different world than May.
We've Brian walked in and
he and he had a guard.
We would turn on him like sharks.
Well if you got got bigger,
if anybody loses way we compliment them.
But yeah,
if somebody gets fab where like you fat
fuck, what are you eating? Lard all day.
This is where comedians man,
we don't play nice like that.
We call it like we see it and we,
you have to have the ability
to laugh at yourself too.
Cause some you're going to fuck up too.
So I should have been hanging out with
you guys when I went through this.
Cause I had to hear about how bad
I looked. Well yeah, well that's,
they think that it's okay to say.
I see what you're saying.
Like it's like culturally
acceptable to talk about someone.
And he retired about a man who
like almost died. You know, in my,
I was passing blood.
Well
to the point where it wasn't
like bloody diarrhea. Oh, it was,
you could,
I was thinking about calling the Red
Cross and having them bring some bags down
and he's bagging it for transfusion rate.
This blood was straight,
perfect blood.
Oh my God. It was like, I just thought,
why am I, where were you with the Arizona?
You said they drank this water.
Yeah. Magic was African water.
You'd be dead right now
unless you're Stephen. Yeah.
Well he drinks tap water though.
This guy's drinking river water. No,
but that's a big
difference, man. I believe.
I believe this guy's on to
something because you know,
people didn't spend their whole
life having waterborne parasites,
making them sick.
You do it and then you like the
ones having high infant mortality.
So like some kids are born and they,
they don't, they don't get it worked out.
And some kids are born in water, doesn't
make them sick. Jumping in the jungle,
water in the wild boys, uh, videos.
That's what we were talking about.
He was just swimming through the
jungle water and it's like, how are,
how are you not dying
if, I guess he wasn't drinking
it, but yeah, you're right.
Just getting in to see if we
get in there. Well, you know,
you ever seen that one of those shows
a about um, I forget the name of it.
It was one of those shows on, I believe
it's on the history channel where they,
they talk about different pathogens are
different parasites and get into your
skin and like eventually burrow their
way into your fucking brain and like,
you know, people don't even realize
there's something wrong with them.
Headaches and transport four foot
one when you're burning calories,
they went swimming in Africa.
It's always like,
well we just happened to be swimming in
some still water in Africa. Like what?
What the fuck are you doing?
It almost still feel sorry for them,
but check it out.
They do down there.
We were talking about in
Ghana they do have that,
that one that goes up your urethra. Yes.
When you pee. Yeah. It follows your urine,
the warmth of your urine something and
it goes right into your penis and camps
and out. That's the real like
that. Totally. We'll get you out.
Know he's the real deal.
If they can't get it all out,
they have to split your deck like
a hot dog and go in and clean it.
You split your hot dogs open.
Some people do and not me.
And microwave does that for them. So
yeah, it does put a weird little crew.
That's was when I was a kid.
I used to like to cut the ends.
I used to like to like it put a little
in the x on the ends and they would
spread out when you put them on the grill.
I don't know why.
I Dunno why I liked that.
I used to like that she'll eat that frozen
or not even like the cook cheese ones
where the cheese,
they had the cheese in the middle of the
dance still is going on in
like a fancy pants way now.
Yeah.
Cheesy dogs.
But I think now you know how like people
always doing like you take not like an
old trick and make it new with food,
but it's kind of like there's like this
sort of retro Foodie kind of thing.
Right.
I think there's a retro foodie movement
right now is same way that pot pies got
fashionable for meatloaf.
It's fashionable.
I think that there's like artisan
cheese dogs know. Yeah, that's funny.
Artisan cheese, cheese dogs. A good
hot dog is an underrated thing.
If you can go to a real good,
get a real good deli hot dog
from a place that makes her own.
They really know what the fuck they're
doing and when you bite into it, it snaps.
You know those hot dogs,
that's an underrated thing.
That was a bright hot doesn't,
yeah.
It's not like the typical ones that come
in the packages and you open them up
and they're all mushy now.
These like you still IX,
they snap when you bite into a man
and that's a real fucking hot dog.
When I'm the stylistic for though,
and this might've been, oh,
you're from the Midwest. All
right. No, no. I grew up in, well,
I was born in New Jersey
mostly. I grew up in Boston. Oh,
I thought you guys talking about going
back home though. He's Ohio. He's,
he's from Ohio. I just got, oh, I'm
really from everywhere. I lived here.
I lived in San Francisco from seven to 11.
I lived in New Jersey to seven San
Francisco, seven to 11 Florida.
11 to 1313 to 14 one part of Boston.
14 to eight 19 another part of Boston.
I smoothed all over the place.
New York, La. But I've been here more
than anywhere. So when you say back home,
people don't know what you're talking.
I don't have a back home.
There's no back home. I guess it would
be Boston. That's where, you know,
I associated people ask me, you know,
that's where I grew up. That's, you know,
that's uh,
that's where I started doing comedy.
That's where everything started for me.
So anything from Joe, lot of Boston,
I just don't like the winter. Well, the
girls, I mean, and not all the girls,
most of the girls. What, what
were you discharged? You don't,
you don't like what you don't like 50%
of the year and you don't like 52% of the
population has, no, no, no, not
say 50 route 52% is all women.
That's like saying I don't like all,
it's not that I don't like
the women in Boston, it's so,
I don't like some of them.
It's a small percentage.
It's probably only like
two or three per percent,
but you're going to run into that yet
that fuck that Kale outside
the fucking ass hall.
Nothing's ever going to work out with you
and they're drunk and they're yelling
at you and it's just do I think you're
being way generous on that number,
by the way, that's 2% come.
That's what you gotta do.
Sometimes you gotta sometimes you
gotta fucking kiss babies. All right,
I'm being a politician here.
What will you miss?
[inaudible] the Midwest before it all
fell apart when the use to be able to go,
if you kept your eyes peeled,
you'd be able to find gas stations that
would have as many as four hotdogs for a
dollar.
Oh yeah.
So that was how bold purchase it was.
Just a thing that was available,
but you could always,
always get two hot dogs for a
dollar. Wow, that's amazing. It was.
I noticed the little rollers,
you know what I mean? Oh yeah,
those seven 11 one so they're just done.
Yeah, and then it had the barn steamer.
They have a bunch of money.
My brother used to,
he used to want to get one of those
roller buns, steamers, and just when,
when like people came
from out of town to visit.
Just like just load that up, put
the buns and steam and be like, Hey,
upon steamers house,
everybody's on their own.
He's really made hot dogs on the
roller bunks or a Costco membership.
I can't tell
my favorite way to eat, man. We
were just in Brazil and a Ari.
Oh my pal Ari Shaffir came with me
and we went to a Brazilian steakhouse.
Was to husker reason really that big
of a difference between Chicago. Damn.
It was good.
[inaudible] is great for Fau goes great.
This place was on another level. It
was called Marius Tude. God Damn,
that food was good.
First of all,
I just think I've been eating grass
fed beef a lot lately. That's my thing.
I try to buy grass fed whenever I can
because whole foods usually has a pretty
good selection of grasp it. It's a little
more expensive, but it tastes different,
man. It tastes like it's
a world different. It's a
healthy animal, you know,
I don't know what they're serving them
in Brazil, but it's the right shit.
That fucking meat was
delicious and they just,
that's where they created that type
of cooking over fire and they'd bring,
you know how, what you ask Korea works
for folks who don't know, there's a,
you get a card and one card is green
and the other side is red and they uh,
this is how they do it.
And most of them,
and they come up to your
table and they see green.
And when you can't take any more,
cause it's all you can eat.
They just keep coming by with more and
more food on, on, on, on swords, you know,
and just such cotton slices of meat
off and they give you tongs and you're,
you're putting you just, it's
an orgy of, of flash. I mean,
it just gets completely out of control.
I've been a good ones before,
but this one in Brazil just
kicked all of them and they pick,
they feed it people zillion barbecue.
Ooh they do man in Rio.
Rio is a, that's a whole nother world
man. It was a whole nother world that,
that place looks, first of
all it's like a movie. It me,
you might as well be an Avatar. You know
when you fly and you see the Jesus on,
on the top of the mountain and then you
see the favelas and then you see like
all these people on the beach or
something. What an amazing place we were.
Me and Ari were all fucked up cause at
the time difference because it's like six
hours ahead of them.
So like it's seven o'clock in the morning.
We were up just chilling on the porch
looking at the uh, the, you know,
these like islands that come out of the
ocean seven o'clock in the morning and
there's kids playing soccer, like playing
a full game of soccer, early risers,
man, nobody's watching them. We
saw them show up with their ball,
like they woke up in the favelas or
wherever the fuck live and nobody,
no one's watching them.
They're like nine years old and they
just wandered out onto the beach and they
all got together and then at one
point in time it started raining.
So they got under a tree and they were
all singing really nine and 10 years old
don't work for the tourism commissioner
said, dude it was, it was wild shit dude.
It was really,
it was a magical thing to watch.
I was watching all these people show
up either barefoot or in flip flops and
shorts on and everybody
just looked chill as fuck.
Everybody was just wandering around.
There was dudes bringing
big truck fulls of coconuts,
not truck fulls right away, excuse me,
bike bike baskets, giant bike baskets.
They all had these bikes.
Everything got moved around with bikes
like ice and coconuts and they would have
a bike and at the front of the bike would
be this giant fucking metal basket and
it would be filled with like, you know,
seven, eight bags of huge bags of ice.
And these fucking dudes be riding these
things uphill and that's, they did.
They go all up and down the beach and
sell their eyes and sell their coconuts
and drop him off and come back and it's
like you're watching another world man,
and everybody's happy as, fuck. I've heard
all these things about Brazil and push.
I was really dangerous and don't go
by in heroin in the projects. Okay,
but if you don't do that,
it's like Copacabana beach.
That might be one of the most beautiful
things that I've ever seen in my life.
Everybody just hanging
out or they're like,
they have the little bars and
little cafes on the beach.
Everybody's just hanging out laughing
like this isn't like the didn't set this
up. They're not waiting for my arrival
to put on a show like one of those North
Korean vice episodes. This is how these
fucking people live every day, all day.
But that's the spirit of, they're in
the news right now just for the day.
It's like a renaissance there right
now or that their is exploding. Yeah.
They're in the middle of having like the
creation of a middle class. You know,
they're, they're the fifth largest economy
in the world now. I mean, it's amazing,
but it's, Brazil's exploding. They
have all sorts of natural resources.
They're just trying to tap into it.
For the longest time it was just like,
you know,
they still have a logging issue.
They still have to deal to what we
were talking about before a station.
That's sad man.
And you,
you see the conflicts between the loggers
and the poor people that live in these
villages and it's scary,
scary shit.
I just think all those dudes
losing their hunting spots. Yeah.
And they cut those trees down.
Listen, I've never been hunting,
but I've been wanting to go
hunting for years and years.
Ricky Schroeder is a buddy of mine and
he's a big hunter and he's always there.
He's always, oh, he's a huge
hunter. That fucking guy. He goes,
we just went last week and he went
to Texas. He take, he has two boys.
One of them is 21 of them is like
1918 and he takes them everywhere.
It takes them hunting in Africa. It takes
some hunting all over the world. He's a,
he's a freak. He loves it. And, uh, his,
his wife his best, he's with my wife.
And so I became friends with them.
So when we've been threatening
to go hunting forever,
I'm just ridiculously busy and
I've never put it together. But uh,
but I, I, I, I think
the ideal way to live,
I watched a Yo MTV, Yo MTV cribs. No, I'm,
I'm combining TV raps. I'm
combining two different shows. MTV
cribs. I watched, uh, you know,
whatever the fuck it's
called with Ted Nugent.
He's living in Michigan and
this is what I became a,
a part of a several year long
fascination with Ted Nugent that I have,
but he lived in his house in Michigan,
unlike fucking, I don't know how many,
a thousand acres or some shit, all high
fenced with animals roaming around.
And he would just get an ATV drive to
his hunting stand and just fuck them up
all day. And that's where it got
all of the food, but not, yeah,
but it'd be like if a farmer is no
different than if a farmer woke up,
went out and shot his cows and acted
like he was hunting them. No, but no,
but it's way better then than
buying store bought food.
He's still in an area where
you know that there's animals,
but that's how he's producing his food.
I've heard that argument that there's
something not cool about it or not.
It just becomes an issue of
cheating becomes a Semana.
It becomes a semantics issue. Right.
So for a real hunter, that's not real.
It's my brother's a hunter. Okay. Like
my brother Matt, very avid hunter,
he also has land where
he runs goats and sheep.
Now when he goes out and
kills a goat or sheep,
he doesn't say that he went
out hunting. Right. You know,
cause it just confuses
because hunting's a word that,
I mean the reason we have languages in
order to be able to discuss complex ideas,
what is the issue is the issue,
the fact that the animals
are contained and you know,
they're definitely going to be there.
Yeah.
It becomes like an issue of what I would
say is there's a term that we use in
the hunting community like fair chase
and it has a pretty pretty solid
definition of being that um,
that the animal has a reasonable
chance of alluding capture.
If you're hunting on a high
wire fence thing, you know,
like Huntington side fence, the animals,
they're not regardless, fair chase.
And so various organizations that may be
like record books that would keep side
like keep track of sizes of animals.
They might not recognize an animal
killed that way. So you might grow up,
it would make sense.
You might grow up in deer on a high
wire fence and Boone and Crockett, um,
which is uh, a scoring organization
that promotes fair chase ethics.
They might say like,
we don't,
we don't welcome an animal taken that
way into our books and we don't even
really appreciate you using our
scoring system. Right. That,
that makes sense. And I'm
definitely like, I'm not,
I'm not familiar with that organization.
I was saying that that might be something
they would say. Now for me, the the,
where it becomes an issue for me, and
I'll say that like I grew up in Michigan,
I've been to Ted Nugent's
annual whiplash bash.
We grew up listening to Fred Barrett.
When I'm in Michigan,
I still cruise the FM dial hoping to pick
up, you know, stranglehold Wang Dang,
you know, whatever. I love it all.
But [inaudible] just done a lot for
hunting isn't a lot to promote hunting.
He does a lot of great conservation work.
He does a lot of charitable work. Milo,
the only way I like part with him,
Dunaway I the,
the thing that he does,
and I don't really understand that,
I don't understand the high wire.
I don't really understand like hunting
that way when you could be hunting other
ways.
I would never tell a brother that he
can't raise animals on his land and he
can't raise farm animals
on his land and shoot him.
I mean it's just not my place to say what
you should be able to do with like an
illegal sense.
But I do feel a sense,
I do have like a proprietary sort
of notion or a sense of ownership.
MMM.
Over how we use the word hunting.
So I want to make sure
that when we as a country,
when we're talking about hunting and
what hunting means and whether hunting's
right or wrong or what hunter should be
allowed to do and should be allowed to
do, I just want to make sure that
we're all talking about the same thing.
And for me,
hunting,
yeah.
In this day and age means of,
of fair chase on.
So when I'm talking about hunting on
top of hunting animals that have a
reasonable chance to get away
that you're hunting animals. Yeah.
I can totally understand that. For
personal satisfaction. However,
if you just trying to
cultivate healthy food and,
and in control your own environment in
that way where you're self sustaining,
which is essentially what he's doing,
hunting,
whatever you want to add on top of that,
providing to all sorts of
different charities and he
gives me the way constantly
to, you know, to needy
families and things.
So it's like he's providing a service
and doing something that he enjoys and
yeah, you know what they are fenced in
and there are, there are animals there,
but this is not what you want.
Aren't you trying to get animals?
Like why is it better if it's hard to do,
like I understand that there's
some satisfaction while
you would go to the woods
or fuck track an animal and find
your name, but if you're, if you're,
what you're trying to do
is be self sufficient and
sustaining life in a natural
way. Well, if you've got
2000 fucking acres man,
and you're just sitting there waiting
for an animal to come on and essentially
it is hunting. You're, you are
hunting, you're not farming,
you know, you're still,
you still have an actual wild environment
that these animals are living in and
you invade that environment to,
to provide your family.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that. I see what you're saying.
But it's one of the bunch of using
Cabelas catalog jerking off with fucking
cammo underwear on, you know like Ooh,
you're putting it, you're put it to me.
Like I'm saying there's
something wrong with it.
Well you are sort of saying that you part
ways with him with the high fence that
you don't think it's fair chase.
No, but yeah, but I'm not saying it,
I'm not arguing that it should be
illegal or I'm not arguing anything.
I'm saying it doesn't appeal
to me because it doesn't have,
it's beyond like Huntington, me
is beyond pragmatism. Like when I,
when I go out to hunt,
I'm not only thinking,
oh this is like a way to get food because
that's in a way mental masturbation.
I have a lot of ways to get
food right, but I can, I can go.
But if you chose to be self
sufficient and to exist off wild game,
wouldn't that be the right way to do it?
Because if you decided to have a fucking
farm, you had 2000 acres and as well,
you know I'm going to do on a tie these
deer up and this little corral here then
shoot one in the head every time.
I didn't want to eat one.
Wouldn't it be better for both the deer
and for you if you allow them three one
free run, a free range, wild
animal live like they should live.
So that is hunting though.
Is it that I would say that it's free
range farming or free range riders.
I prefer wild game. I really do el
cause like some of my favorite food.
I love Venison. I like like a gaming
meat. It's delicious to me. Wouldn't,
I don't say gaming in a negative way.
But you know there's a,
there's a taste that a wild
animal Brazilian beef because
when you're on a like,
like animals on a strict grass died,
it takes them longer to come of weight.
So you might like here in 14 months it,
if you're finishing a mountain grain,
you can bring your car to
slaughter weight and you know,
13 14 million people don't
even know folks. But it takes,
it takes three years to bring them up.
It could take two years, three years,
bring them up.
So you're eating the older animal.
When you go to a supermarket folks,
and you get a steak and you
see that marbling, you know,
you see like a delicious ribeye and it's
all filled with fat and they go, Ooh,
that's gonna be great on the grill.
That's fucking sick animal.
That's 10 animals sick that animals
eat the shit they shouldn't be eating.
They're eating some shit they
would never eat in nature.
They're supposed to be in grass. He's
eaten more than he would eat. Yeah,
he's eating more than he would eat.
And he's,
he's eating in a different way and
he's not being exercised. Right.
And if you're getting cows that
are raised in really cheaply,
he might actually be eating some
cow protein as well. I mean,
that's where mad cow disease, he is
come the legal now. But illegal now,
but it's been done, you know,
but I want to give back.
I want to really quickly get back
to the idea of of the high fence,
fair chase hunting grounds and Jason,
listen,
I'm totally playing devil's advocate.
I know you are,
and you're raising valid points because
we're talking about two different things.
You're talking about farming.
Yeah. Hunting on your own spot.
We know the animals are like it. Listen,
if you have a pond in your backyard,
they're not, those fish
aren't going anywhere, bitch,
they're just going to sell.
They're not going anywhere. Man. Fishing,
I think it's fishing, drainage ditch,
and I say it's still fishing. It's still
fishing. If you have your own pond,
it's still fishing. You can't say
we're talking about very loose,
slippery terms. Yeah. I would say
that if you took a Kiddie Pool, okay,
let's say you have a Kiddie pool and
I throw three or four bluegills in the
Kiddie Pool, I would not say
I went fishing today. Right?
Because I caught those blue goes
that I had put into my kitty pool.
What if it's a pippy comes different?
What if it's upon,
I would still not call that fishing.
If I had like a pond in my backyard
that I made, I wouldn't go. Yeah,
I went fishing today. No, it wouldn't be.
You made pine where I lived in Boston,
I lived in Newton, Massachusetts
on this street called Ellis Street.
And if you go down Ellis Street, there's
the Charles River on the left hand side,
which would have these
monster fucking carp.
I mean you had never seen like there was,
there was times when they were spawning
when they were all going to get
underneath the waterfall.
It was fucking nuts, man.
Me and my friends would go there and
these be carp that were like, you know,
as we were like, you know, 13 years old.
So as far as we could put
our hands out left and right.
That's how big these fish where they
were an enormous, enormous fish.
And then down the road just a little
bit was this really tiny bass pond.
It was tiny,
but there was a few big basket and like
three and four pound bass in it and they
would just fucking off all these other
fish and this really small environment,
but it was still fishing.
It was hard to catch those fucks.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
It's slippery terms and I can't,
I go fishing.
I can cast all the way to the other end.
I'd have,
if I had a one ounce head weight upon,
it could very well been
fishing and I'll say this,
and this may be what would help
explain my perspective on this.
I think that many aspects of what we do,
like we appreciate challenge and
we appreciate uncertainty. Okay.
If I go out to hunt on public land or
unfenced lands are uncontrolled lands,
if I go out to hunt,
I'm going out knowing that I'm entering
into a complicated relationship,
a complicated arrangement with the land,
and there's a very strong chance
that I will not be successful.
And to overcome that,
I have to strive and try harder and
concentrate more than be better and
challenge myself.
So when I fulfill my goal,
it's knowing that I did it against some
kind of like some kind of adversary,
which should be the uncertainty of the
landscape of the availability of animals.
And that I overcame that through
skill and concentration and effort.
And so when I get that
animal and eat that animal,
I'm reliving and enjoying that challenge
and the fulfillment of that challenge.
And I think that people have,
they do similar things in many ways
where they hunt or not. For instance,
people go to Italy, right to eat Italian
food. You could just as well argue,
why would you go all that way?
Wouldn't it be so much more efficient
just to eat Italian food here?
And you're like,
yeah,
but they're ones that being more of
a set of experiences that come with,
with the reality of it.
So while I would never say that my
brother shouldn't raise a lamb and then go
kill it,
he would never,
because he cares about these terms
and cares about these things.
He would never bullshit himself and act
like he hunted that he was out hunting
sheep. I wouldn't do it
naked naked. I'd put,
I'd put war paint on and shit and I would
hold the knife only in my teeth until
I got ahold of the actual,
and that wouldn't be hunting.
That would be you being out being away.
It sounds like with a knife.
I totally agree with him
and I think when met anyway,
I'm not saying that should be illegal,
but if you want to get naked with warpage,
sheep can run and the sheep could
bite than the sheep can fight back.
If it chooses to,
let me just kill it because I'm
the Apex Predator of my backyard.
Well that's the fucking,
that's the sheeps fall.
What Nugent is pretty much doing is
using a cheat code in a video game. Well,
he's in a much bigger place
now. He moved to Texas. Yeah,
I'm fascinated with Ted Nugent. Moved to
another place outside of Waco. A giant,
much bigger.
Same sort of a situation.
Do you wanna you wanna hear my Waco deer
hunting story? Sure. Okay. By the way.
But before you say that Waco,
the way you explain that,
I just want to say eloquently put, that
was a beautiful way of describing the,
the, the, the spiritual quest
of hunting and that it's so,
it's a lot more than just acquiring
food and just a about harvesting and
cultivating food. It's a whole experience
for you. It's a, it's a, it's a conquest.
It's a challenge. It's a, it's, there's
a, there's, it is an an ancient game,
you know, and, and you're, you're
playing it with honor, you know,
and I totally appreciate that. And then
what I was saying, you know, as I said,
devil's advocate
question was though,
you raise raising valid one and
it's stuff I never thought of it.
Now I understand.
I mean like tension surrounding the
issue of hunting has like always existed.
Know,
I mean like you look at like the old
testament like Esau and Esau and Jacob.
I mean it's like right in the beginning
there's been like tension of what,
you know,
how we all go and get our food.
We have a responsibility to be cause
we're thinking animals just comes up.
It's like, so I'm beyond the point
at a time when I used to for a trap,
I used to do lot of trapping and sell
animals and at the firm market I started
trapping like very lightly when I was
10 and I was tracking very heavily,
you know, in, in my early twenties.
And is that how you learned how to
cook a beaver tail? That was nasty.
That might be one of the nastiest
whatever. It's interesting to eat that,
but let me just look at that age. Okay.
If like my blood would boil when I hear
the word Peter, like I f I just want,
when I heard like anyone who was
against hunting or trapping or whatever,
I would just be like,
I just want to like tear into him.
I was so full of anger about it. Do
you know what I'm saying? Yeah, sure.
And in some way maybe I didn't understand,
you know,
my own arguments and stuff,
but now you,
there's nothing you could say
against hunting would bother.
You would piss me off. You could
say a lot of things against hunting.
The dot would be like, well, you
know, there's this way looking at it,
but there's nothing you could really bring
up that would make mad like whatever.
Part of my brain used to be able to get
mad at people who don't agree with me.
It's just gone now. I find him the
coward one is the most fascinating one.
You know, Oh you coward, you want to
kill innocent animals. I'm like, wow.
And it's always for people
with leather shoes on and shit.
It's like my take on animals
has always been I love animals.
As long as they love me back,
everybody else is getting eaten
or get the fuck out of my way.
There's a war going on between
all animals on this planet.
There's a constant battle for dominance.
We're just so far ahead of the other
animals that we kind of have forgotten.
It's a war and we're like
looking out for them,
looking out for the other animals,
sometimes more than we're looking out
for 10 people and that's on a regular
basis. There's a lot of people out
there that are just confused, weird,
sensitive people that for whatever
reason they couldn't imagine killing and
eating an animal. And when you don't
realize is how many animals die buying.
You're getting your fucking lettuce yell
any rabbits and rats and rodents and
gophers just get chopped up in
those machines that are, that are,
that are picking various vegetables and
pulling them out of the ground that they
kill a, an incredible amount of animals.
Every time they harvest veteran,
well not that,
but the amount of habitat destruction
that went into creating a farms. It's,
it's impossible to live a life
that you can drive your self nuts,
but it's impossible to live a
life without blood on your hands.
But I'm not sure it must live
a life like I live a life with
blood on my hands in a much more
like recognizable, visceral way.
And I think that, you know, I was having
this discussion earlier tonight where,
you know, Camille Pauley and she's
kind of a, like a provocateur,
maybe she has this thing,
she wrote peg and theory of sexuality
and in it she talks to the whole point of
civilization.
Like the whole point was to lift us up
from having to dude from being obligated
to do things we don't want to do.
You know,
like we don't need to worry about like
what is natural and what's not natural
because we've had this very
elaborate creation we've made.
We don't need to treat our own raw sewage.
A lot of us don't fix our own car.
We don't build our own home. So for
me to sit here and say like, Oh,
you're not a man if you
don't kill your own food.
I can't really say that anymore because
there's a lot of things that go into my
existence that I'm not
doing. You know, there's,
there's like I'm being supported
by all these things we've created,
but in this one area I do
choose to still do that.
And it gives me a connection
into a much broader world.
I was going to make another
point earlier by camera.
What the hell is gonna talk about?
Oh my Waco deer hunt story.
It's not that great of a story.
It's not that great. Well,
kind of hunting with Ted
[inaudible] who was a cannon.
So I was not near Waco and, and,
and I was just like the guests,
I was actually visiting and I want to
be in that they have, they're like, oh,
we'll have Bob over the neighbor. Bob.
Bob Likes to hunt you and Bob can talk.
Bob escaped from the camp.
Remember back when they burned it.
So tell him how he got out. All
right. Shot my shelf. I'll fed.
So Bob tells me we'll,
we'll go hunting in the morning and Bob
takes me out and we drive out into the
dark on this farm and
Waco and he tells me,
he dropped me off at this ladder stand,
which is like a plant,
like a prison guard platform.
Then you climb up in there and he tells
me that feeders or kick on at seven.
And I honestly, I was so naive at the
planet and he know what this meant, but,
but he has an automatic feeder,
so the animals just worn out.
It spits corn out at seven.
How do you feel about that?
About people planting food? That's of
course the same thing. Right? Well,
that he see, I could tell that
you're like, uh, you're, you're,
you're a professional
interviewer because I'm not even,
this is the first time we were near
Hobby interview because you're, you're,
you're, you're narrowing your
questions down in such a fine point.
Where within the hunting world,
let me fix my Waco story.
The don't forget what you just
asked me. No, well it's, it's,
you're saying that the feeders,
come on,
we'll get the kick on at seven at 6:55
AM dear start coming out of the woods in
converging on the thing for the seven
o'clock feed session. Oh my God.
I said to myself at that, at
that moment, I said, I cannot,
I will not kill a deer under
these circumstances. Wow.
So I want to killed every
one of those dumb fucks.
But it's driven by,
it's like it to me
violated a sort of packed.
I understand. Do you understand?
Yeah, no, totally. I'm on now.
When you ask about planning food,
you're going to need an interesting thing
because a thing in hunting used to be,
there used to be a lot more,
she's a lot more one thing in a do you
just take bait out and put it in a feeder
and dump it in the woods.
Right.
And in some places that it's
illegal someplaces it's frowned on.
In some places it's legal
and perfectly acceptable.
Depends on culturally how people
do things. Where you're from.
Another version of that is that you just
have honest to goodness agricultural
lands.
So that would be,
that was a cornfield that there where
they raise corn to sell and to market and
deer are drawn to this and you go and sit
on the edge of this cornfield and hunt
deer.
And so a lot of guys that might do that,
they might sit like an apple orchard or
an Alfalfa field or on the edge of the
cornfield and they would say,
oh,
I don't agree with baiting dear the way
you do it where you just don't the corn
in the woods, but me sitting
on a Cornfield as legitimate.
Oh I see.
I've watched a hunting shows where they
show you how to grow crops that are
going to attract this and this broad
on in some areas where they banned like
maybe it's illegal bait, it's illegal
to donate to have a big machine.
It just unloads corn.
Then is you plant a like pho agricultural
crop call a food plot and you might
plan it with no intent to harvest,
but you plan it.
So you plan a little Alfalfa patch and
animals come on and it winds up being
just as bad. No, no, I'm not saying
that as it being, it's like a grain.
It grays, the area of what? So in the
hunt, in the hunting community of,
of people who are think about these
things and they're always weighing like,
how can we continue to have a sustainable
relationship with our resources in
light of changing technologies the
same way it becomes really difficult to
interpret the constitution because
we look at it like, okay, you know,
right to bear arms, but did that mean
you can have a howitzer? You know?
So we're always like going like,
things have changed.
So now what do we do in hunting or eyes
looking at these things that change.
Like people just hadn't fought.
I mean, people had historically,
but it wasn't widespread practice to
grow bait out in the woods and now it
isn't. So it becomes a debate, like
how do we, how do you feel about that?
How about you don't, you're
not for the planters, you know,
for the food that just dumps it out at
any given time. Whatever you call it. Not,
not for it. It's not appealing
to me. Like that's not how,
that's not how I like to hunt.
Yeah.
It's the same thing as if I
fishy in bucket. I, yeah. Again,
I would never say I would never advocate
that it'd be abolished because we
control, like we have ways
that we regulate honeymoon,
regulate hunting through season length
through how many harvests tickets are
allowed. But there's a plane
way that we can control harvest.
So as long as a group of people aren't,
you know,
damaging a resource irreparably, I'm
not going to then go and say like, Oh,
you should do this way and the way I
hunt. Right. And the way you hunts wrong.
But it has to be the kind of hunting
that's most rewarding to me and that I
spend my time doing is I like
to hunt bigger tracks of land,
more physically grueling hunts.
I like to be.
Why are more where it brings more of
an immersion into a wilderness setting
where it really draws on more skills
on my part where I feel more um,
engrossed. I like to get, like,
I feel like I'm really hunting when I
get to a point where no other thought
invades my mind.
Okay.
If I could get into a situation
where I'm not being like, oh,
I forgot to call my mom again, you know,
I should really call my mom next Sunday.
Like when I can get away from any
thought and I'm just strictly doing that.
Yeah.
That's what I feel. Right. You know?
And so that's Kinda like what I'm
pursuing in really. I'll go through,
you know, when I'm home. So if I'm not
traveling a lot and I'm home, I'll eat,
you know,
pound or more game meat.
My wife eats slightly less than that per
day. If I'm cooking dinner for her, um,
you know, we'll go through my, I give a
lot of way. So when I go into my year,
I'm always looking at what I
can really go through. Well,
how much meat can I actually can? How much
do you eat from a supermarket? I don't,
well, from a supermarket, I don't eat
any meat. I'll eat meat in restaurants.
I eat in restaurants,
but I would never buy meat
in the supermarket and
bring it into my house. Wow.
Nah, we just, he gave me but I
have like tons of great gaming.
I know how to handle it well. So that's
what we eat. How long does it stay? Good.
I'll usually on the long end I will
keep me in my deep freezer for one year.
I don't let things go longer one
year cause I generally practice a,
was it last in first out.
So the,
the animals are harvested
this year, September, October,
November, hunting seasons.
I don't get into those until
I've finished last year stuff.
So when I get into the, to the mid summer
I might give away a lot of game meat.
You know, maybe I'll give away 40 pounds
or 50 pounds a game, eat to friends.
I know who use it well cause then I'm
trying to clear out my stores knowing that
I'm going to be coming into a
new season of a lot more. But,
but the reason I brought this up was it,
there's a finite amount
that I need the non abuse.
So if I know that I can achieve that goal,
which is my primary goal,
to build a feed myself on game me,
then I,
then I start thinking about
the quality of those hunts.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Like if you told me you could
go to location a and kill
an elk in an hour or you
could go to location B and work your
ass off and kill an elk in 10 days,
this is going to sound like I'm, I'm
telling you bs about really would pick B.
That doesn't sound like bs
at all because I'd be like,
well that sounds like an amazing,
that sounds like an amazing trip and
I'm going to come out of it with stories
and things that happened and I still
will wind up with my, you know,
150 200 pounds, 300 pounds
depending on the size of the elk,
elk meat that I know I'm going to
use. So I just get more, you know,
how much does it affect the flavor
of the animal when you freeze it,
not adverse. There's a lot of
misconceptions about freeze and meat.
Meet. We'll hear from
her. The term of aging.
Yes you meet will still age in a freezer,
not still meet,
will age and freeze it like there's some
breakdown and the breakdown of me is
particularly obvious when you look at the
way fat because fat will actually in a
longterm it'll rot in the freezer. If
you take a really fat, like you take,
let's say you take a pork chop and
it's got a big band of fat on it,
you put that thing in your freezer
for a year. When you pull it out,
that band of fat is going to have,
it's going to probably have yellowed.
It might even smell rancid. Even those in
the freezer and the meat would be fine.
So when I put games and game meat fat,
like on the Deere family particularly,
we call it tallow. It's a difference, a
very waxy. It's a different kind of fat.
That stuff really does not do well in
a freezer and it's not even good fresh.
It has a very low melt point. So
Hi Mel points. So when you eat it,
you take a hot piece and eat it.
It solidifies in your mouth,
like coats your roof, your mouth
with that wax and kind of stuff.
People just generally to trim it off.
If I take a good piece of meat and trim
it and put it in my freezer or a year or
I took a piece and trend to put in my
freezer three months and I gave you a
Pepsi challenge between three months and
12 months. There's no way you'd pick,
there's no way you'd pick it out.
That's in a deep freeze. And that's,
and I wrap all my games, very care. If
I do a very tight layer of plastic wrap,
squeeze all the air and
like get it really good.
And then I do it in wax freezer paper
and then I keep it in a freezer at a low
setting. So you'd, is it a vacuum
seal? No, I don't. I don't like those.
How come?
Because the bags get punctured.
If you know that everyone's going to be
wearing like velvet gloves and no one's
going to be moving this stuff
around, they're great. But even,
but those bags is rubbing against each
other or someone's like carelessly.
You know how when you're rummaging
through your freezer and looking for
something to rummage through your fridge,
look in the phone,
you puncture those bags in the bag,
relies on the seal so the minute you
puncture it you wait a while later and you
just have like a big loose bag full of
ice crystals and freezer burned stuff.
It just isn't like archival
the way I want it to be.
And I've dinked around with
different packaging like that.
Have you tried double layers, like the
vacuum seal and then yeah, it's just,
and like for speed issues, if I had a
way that they didn't ever get punctured,
I would use them more. But for me I
just, even when I've had them work,
I just haven't seen that for the way I
handle it in the way I go through it and
the way I store it and what I store.
I have not seen that it works any
better even when it's perfect.
It doesn't work any better
than how I like to wrap it.
And the way I like to wrap it definitely
works better in the long run cause it
doesn't wind up getting
punctured and full ice crystals.
How long have you been living like this?
Yeah,
you know,
I grew up like my father was a big hunter
and we grew up doing a lot of hunting
and fishing. I started fishing when
I was, you know, three or four.
I started hunting at
seven or eight years old,
killed my first deer and I was 13 and
started hunting deer and I was 11.
We always ate a lot of deer meat, but
we have, we didn't live a conscientious,
we hadn't made a conscientious
decision to just eat game. We just,
we had a lot of it and
ate a lot of it but,
but we didn't look at eating that
differently than, than eating beef.
And you'd go in our freezer anytime
you'd find a wide array of meats.
When I left home to go to college, I went
to college in Sioux St Marie, Michigan,
um, w with a lot of phenomenal hunting
around Lake Superior State University.
And we were all very, like my
friends. And I were very skilled,
pretty seasoned hunters by that point.
And we were broke the way you
are when you go to college.
And we found that we could,
uh,
just kill deer and eat them
and we would buy, we would eat.
I remember me and my two roommates,
we went through four deer between
October one in the beginning of Christmas
break. So wow. So like December 15th,
October one to seven for dear
parties at your house. We,
our mantra was burgers for lunch, steaks
for dinner. I mean, we're burgers,
we would just eat.
Yeah.
We eat ground meat at lunch and
we fished a lot of salmon, right.
Because the Saint Mary's river
is falls right through town.
We'd fish salmon out of that.
And that was the first time that I,
that I started to live that way.
And I mean,
and I began to live that way
just as out of necessity.
But then necessity dovetailed or like
blended very quickly into a lifestyle
choice. Like one month into that or
let's say that first year we did that.
So December 15th, um, you know,
we finished that fourth year.
At that point if you,
if you had, you know,
like of God had come down
and giving me $1 million,
a lot of things would've changed.
Diet would not have changed at that.
I fell so in love so quickly with that,
just like very deliberate style
and we have, you know, as humans,
like you alluded this tour to this earlier
where we have a lot of energy and a
lot of physical attributes and physical
skills that we just don't need to use
anymore because the things we've done
and it makes me very happy and feel very
fulfilled just to do that.
And I'm not and I don't like go out and
say it that it would do the same thing
to you.
Like I don't like to be where I don't
like the sound or be in a position where
I'm telling people where I'm
advocating to people like, Oh,
if you're unhappy you'll find
tremendous happiness by hunting.
I'm just saying for me it was,
it changed my life and gave me a sense of,
of purpose and fulfillment that is matched
now only buy like professional things
and my family things.
It's on that level for me.
So I've just lived that way since then.
Whoa.
Ever watched any of the vice stuff?
vice.com and read any of their
magazines or any of that stuff? No,
there's a company called vice know.
I have one other out,
cause my agent represents the
author who published a device. They,
they put out some wild shit and one of
them was called Heimos Arctic refuge and
Hyman. Yeah. He lives in the
upper right. There's a whole,
but there's a book about him
too though. Is it really? Yeah.
There's a book about him. Well, hi Mo. I
can't remember his last year. Couth yeah,
that's right. Yeah, that's right. Yeah.
They followed this dude up in, uh,
you know he's in like North
East Alaska, right? Yeah.
They did this after this book came out.
It's a phenomenal book, man. Really? Well,
he's, he's an amazing cat man. It's a,
this guy is just walking around out there.
He doesn't have a car. He doesn't have,
I mean he's got a little hot, which is,
you know, something that he has built. Oh,
it's basically a log house.
He traps for the third markets.
He traps and he shoots Caribou and
he fishes and you know, and he's,
he's a very smart guy. He's
not an idiot, you know,
he said he's never around much people be,
could be besides his wife,
but he was talking about how he believes
that, you know, he's a very, he's a,
he's really happy and he thinks that
this is how a man is supposed to live.
The man is supposed to live a,
a hunter gatherer existence and
then there's a genetic connection.
May Be even he was
insinuating that this is like,
it's something in our DNA that
satisfied at a living like that.
And most people that are depressed
and most people that are,
that are bummed out and they live in
a a really unfulfilling life. I mean,
think about what they're doing.
And W W you're,
your body's set up to get all these
sort of biological rewards from sex,
from acquiring food, from a acquiring,
physical success, whatever the,
whatever it is that it's difficult to
acquire, your body gets these rewards.
If all the sudden you're in a cubicle
and every day it's just the same stupid
shit. There's no rewards,
there's no nothing, there's no,
none of those biological needs,
those holes and those holes are filled in.
You know, we've, we've really created
a very, very strange society that, uh,
very few people have been
able to navigate successfully.
It's almost like we've got this really
complicated thing that we have to run,
but with no handbook. And so almost
everyone's doing it wrong, you know,
and almost everyone's doing it
wrong for the, for the human body.
Your windup was surprise things too.
Like the other night before I came here,
we were trying,
my wife and our busily trying to find
sources of drafts in our home because we
had a good cold snap.
And you know,
we have like a lot of obligations and
somewhat complicated lives and a lot of
things we're trying to do.
But we spent the entire afternoon
blocking up drafts as we were because like
that night after blocking up drafts there
was kind of like this or of happiness
and be kind of like got along in a
different way than we normally get along
having like accomplish this,
this issue of maintaining our
homes and like she'd be warm.
It was like we kind of like
just got launched into this.
This is something that was like just
like older and different, you know, and,
and it's interesting you bring up the,
the,
the guy that makes his living
as a fur trapper, you know,
gets his cash income from,
for traffic.
Because when I trapped
for it really made me,
I became kind of miserable trapping for
because I got into for trapping at a
time when for prices were pretty high.
Okay.
Look for prices in the late 1970s were
really high just for a lot of reasons,
but basically coincidentally
for fashionable and a
bunch of different places.
What animals are you talking about?
Oh,
like what would be like traditional fur
bearing animals in North America would
be on the, on the smaller side would
be urban and weasels and muskrats.
And on the bigger side would be links
in wolf and an in between that you have
may have things like me, wolf, raccoon,
Fox, cow. I've never tracked wolf,
but what I used to trap me personally,
I would trap Muskrat, mink, raccoon,
Fox, coyote, beaver, Otter.
I'd skin and sell some possums.
I'd skin cell, some skunks.
Now when I got into a trap and I sat in
my first trap in 1984 and you could sell
a Muskrat for five or $6 and I could
mow a lawn for five or six bucks.
So it was obviously great.
The from argus only went
downhill from there.
And by the time the mid
nineties came around,
mmm.
It was hard to make any money trapping.
And I realized that I would
go out and like one year,
I remember it was the second
last year ever trapped.
I remember I had the end of the year,
I had 250 muskrats,
52 raccoons, 13 beavers, you know,
and I'm looking at this big pile of
things that I went out and harvested and
worked my ass off to get.
And the value of all this
stuff wasn't set by me.
The value of all this stuff was set by
factors that I couldn't even begin to
understand the economic climate
and China, um, weather trends.
It would be that at the time women in
Italy would buy a fur coat that weighed as
much as 13 pounds. Women in Asia wouldn't
buy for fur coat the weight anymore,
nine pounds. So like southern
raccoons, which had a lighter hide.
We're bringing a lot more than northern
raccoons even though they were less good
quality because there's a more of a
demand and you wind up looking at all this
animal life,
all those wildlife and wilderness life.
And we're trying to like set,
you know what it's worth.
And I didn't have any control
over what it was worth.
And it felt in some ways like to when I
later discovered more like does hunting
for food cause I started hunting for food
or after I quit trapping for money and
when I hunt for food it's
like I set the value.
It was a non-negotiable value to me.
You know,
if I killed a squirrel it was a
meal, you know what I mean? It was,
there was that it was a meal.
There was no money involved in it.
Did it bother you? The idea of
killing animals as a commodity?
Did it feel like ethical? It didn't
feel so much unethical. Diesel good.
Yeah.
It didn't feel good because I didn't
like the idea that all these values were
set by other things I didn't understand.
And I also didn't like why is that?
If you look at,
let's say a trap me and I know that that
makes gonna wind up in Italy somewhere.
It just winds up being like,
it feels to me like here I am like
catching this mink and there's, and,
and for me to see the ultimate product
is just so diffused. It's so far away,
you know, it's like some in
Italy and might buy this coat,
I'll get $22 for the mink.
It wound up being that I just,
it stopped being fun for me because I
felt too much like that everything was out
of my control.
The business I'm in now.
Hold on a second before I let you go any
further, I, you're really confusing me.
I'm not sure I understand why you're,
you're fixated on this idea that you don't
control how much it's worth. You know,
that that's what was frustrating
about it. Um, when you,
when you talk about animals
and like hunting and you know,
this ethical hunting thing did,
did it bother you at all?
Do you just setting these traps and these
animals are just walking in and you're
just selling their furs? I Dunno,
that never bugged him in a way.
Like one thing that bugged me only in
retrospect because you know you skills
come before ethics in life.
Like I knew how to trap muskrats before
I learned to think about you were young.
How young were you when you started
in the last time trap muskrats.
So I didn't know.
So it was just a party.
You're looking back on it
now looking back on it now,
there's a couple things
that I did that bother me.
Is that about how the animals died?
No,
it would be that some,
some violate like some violations of the
law that did like where you could catch
otters north of a certain line.
Okay.
I would catch otter south of that line
and in lie about where I caught him and
the reason you weren't supposed to catch
himself that line is because there's a
reintroduction effort and daughters didn't
have a population that could support
it. But in this pursuit of trying
to like make money trapping,
I found myself doing things to make
money that were unethical. Yeah.
And no one was forcing me to do this.
This is things that I was doing.
Also in trapping,
you wind up generating an
enormous amount of, of, of, of,
of waste of flesh. When you tapping
these animals with a dying instantly,
most of them or how long does it take
before they die? Things are dying quickly.
The water species die quick.
Anything near water is good.
Die Quick cause you so your rig it to die.
So like if I'm setting for Moss grads,
they get something called
a body gripping trap.
The body group and trap in and of
itself is lethal in, it'll kill it.
A matter of minutes or less.
A body gripping traps set underwater
to things dead essentially. Instantly.
It's rounds. Yeah. I mean it was
given a mat. It'd be like if I took a,
if you were already underwater and
I like somehow hit you with a truck
underwater,
did you drown into the truck hit you?
So these are professional and
constructive traps. Oh yeah. Steel traps.
So then we, are you still cool
with those today? Is that,
I mean how do you feel about that today?
I've done.
I've done trap and as recently
as a year and a half ago,
trapping with beaver with body
gripping traps and snares. You,
but you have a problem
with feeders for deer. No,
I don't have a problem
with fetus for deer.
It doesn't appeal to me to hunt that
way, but it doesn't bother you. Trapping.
Trapping is a difference. I
rarely trap, but when you do,
it's of a pragmatic sort
of as focus. Yeah, like if,
if that's the best way to follow the trap
beaver now I would like for instance,
the beavers I've trapped most recently
I had pillows and a hat made out of the
hides and I ate the meat. You
ate the beaver? Yeah. Wow.
What the fuck is beaver tastes like? You
know? Honestly, if you, if you don't,
if you don't get now there, there
are herbivorous man, but yeah.
Gotcha. It's such, it's such low harden.
It's such low hanging fruit.
It's like one of the things,
like whenever the subject
of beaver trap and comes up,
it's such low hanging fruit to
southern vagina. Joan has to go for it.
Imagine now having discuss beaver
trapping for the last 20 years.
There's no beaver anymore, by the
way. That shit, if you find a beaver,
that shit's bad. That's a girl's
not shaving it, getting it grows.
Keep it up with the times. You
can't call that a beaver, you know,
you call it a hipsters go t at the most.
That's the most you'll tolerate.
You're not going to tolerate
a beaver or Kale. Um, so, uh,
on the show we were talking about this
really what you alluded to it and we said
we're going to get back to, we didn't,
you trapped a beaver and one of your, uh,
one of those living like all these other
people live. You were up in Canada. Yeah.
We're just body gripper traps. Is that
was, that was the same type of trend.
That's an instant kill
trap. And then you, uh,
you eat the beaver and you eat
the tail, Huh? Yeah. If you don't,
beaver has cast or
glands and at times the,
the cast or gland,
it has been more valuable than,
than to be retired as a caster.
Glen,
there's two glands that sit
on either side of their vent,
like basically where if your
kidneys were not against your back,
and they were kind of upfront, it almost
be like the same scale. It's like how,
how big a caster.
Glen is just a,
it's a pasty substance that they
secrete and it's like a calling carpets.
Very sweet.
You've never smelled anything in the
wild that smells like beaver caster and
people used to use it for
perfumes now that you oh yeah,
it's, it's, it's gorgeous.
It's a gorgeous smell.
They would add it to perfumes they had,
they would add it to various
pharmaceuticals in the old days.
Now a lot of beaver cast or goes into
making beaver Lewer because to take a
beaver from one pond and go to another
pond and put his caster out beavers in
that ponder and get pissed and they're
gonna want to kill that beaver. Really?
Yeah. It's like, it's a calling card.
So it's just a kind of a way of saying
like it's kind of way of saying fuck you
almost for like a beaver to go into a
new area. Like he migrates up stream,
he gets to a new pond,
he's going to lay down,
he's going to build up a little pile of
mud and secrete some his gland on there
and he's saying like, I'm in
town. Wow. Deal with it. I'm here.
So the big beaver market for castor glands
is artificially doing that to get the
beavers pissed off.
A lot of beaver caster will get sold
into making lewers for a variety of
species. It's beaver like skunk
essence winds up being a deterrent?
No, no. A lot of animals
at at small doses.
A lot of animals are curious
about the smell of skunk. Really.
If you take beaver caster and this,
it doesn't need be at low doses,
but beaver cast or is appealing.
So you'll trap.
I used to take casters from the beavers.
I caught an hour.
Would Adam and lure
that I'd use for coyote,
I'd add them in lieu or that I
used for Fox. I'd add him in the,
or use for raccoon addendum and all
that kind of lure in various quantities
because it's just,
it's a seductive smell that just seems
to be universally appealing. Wow.
And what is the or the animals attracted
because they think they're going to eat
the, the, the beavers glands or is
it just a smell? I think it draws,
I think a number of things are
going on curiosity. Um, and,
and perhaps it just has a,
like the way fish who've never
seen a worm will eat worms.
There's certain things that just speak
to you like on an olfactory and visual
sense.
If for some reason beaver caster
lewers in a wide variety of animals.
Now when you say you know, Louis for
Fox or Lewis for different animals,
how do you, you have, you couldn't
construct these yourself? Yeah,
like for instance, I used to
take a house cat meat. Okay,
but because you kill a cat.
No,
here's it's a law now you have to
promise you. You're, let me tell you,
let me explain everything so far. Yeah,
you have no, nothing's been too crazy.
Dairy farmers will keep house cats.
They dairy farmers like to have a lot of
cats around a control mice populations.
Okay.
So they want plenty of cats.
You get to have too many cats
because they're not, they're not the,
they're came catch.
These casts are essentially Farrell.
The hang around a farming operation.
You get too many and they start,
they'll transmit diseases back and forth
talking to new plasma and you wind up
with no cats.
So when a dairy farmer in my area would
get to be where he had way too many
cats, he would like, I used to go
out and shoot the cats on a bounty.
Wow.
So I would shoot cats for five bucks or
10 bucks or whatever because they would
want to trim back. They'd
be like, we got to,
I have to get rid of 50% of these cats
are, I'm gonna have problems. Wow.
So the cats are only existing on these
mice or are they giving them food as well?
No, the guys, they'll
definitely put feed out.
They'll get food out
and they role of wild.
And the other thing is from like,
if you imagine these farmyards as being
like a little nexus of, of cat stuff,
you'll wind up with feral cats spinning
off of that and they can have a
dramatically negative impact on like
ground nesting birds and things.
So beyond shooting cats around a farm,
it's common practice in
agricultural areas to kill cats.
That goal certifiably feral because we're
looking at them as being competition.
Like we want to have,
you know,
pheasant or grouse or to have
around and the cats like, uh,
a non-natural competitor. And so in the,
in the great spirit of all predators,
the same way a wolf will kill a coyote
and a Cowlick Hill Fox will a cat.
Now you're saying this very pragmatically,
but please don't. Yeah, but I used to,
when I was making bait,
I would get the cats that I would use
when I was doing control work for a dairy
farmer.
And I would take the cat and I would bone
out the back hams and I would take the
out the back hams mean their legs.
I would take the meat off the back legs.
No bones. Okay. Would up
in the morning copycat ham,
I would put that in a in a,
in a one quart mason jar,
one quart glass jar and now bury that
in the sand somewhere where it was like
pretty cool. So I had a controlled
temperature cause I don't want to put,
I couldn't put my mom's fridge so
I'd buried that coffee down the sand.
I'd leave it there for about
a week and it would be,
it would become what we would call tint
tainted. Not like taint lake, you know,
10 you're asking your balls, but like
it would become slightly rotted at that.
Once it got to be the perfect kind
of rotten, like a little bit tainted,
I would add glycerin to it,
like a preservative to halt the rock.
Then I would add in small amounts of
other stuff like output, put pulverized.
I would take beaver caster and mince it
up in a mortar and pestle and add some
beaver caster into it. I might add
a little bit of fish oil into it.
I might add like glands
from a Red Fox into it.
Is this is all common
trappers are, no, no, no.
There's not all travelers, but some
trappers, there's recipes for this.
Do they sell this stuff like a Nordic
versions or type in type in trapping
louvers on your deal there. My head sets
wigging out. Yeah, mine is too Brian.
This thing keeps fucking up.
The sound on this thing is a mess.
That's why I keep grabbing it. You're
your connections off somehow or another.
So an ounce, a trapping Lou are usually
sells for five or six bucks for an ounce,
seven 50 maybe for an ounce.
And so I would make my lures this way
and I would then use these lures to lure
and animals in, in, you know, to
lure and Fox and stuff. Other stuff.
I would just use a piece of
stuff like all summer out.
If I was flying fish to eat,
I would just save the heads and use
the heads for mink. Just that simple,
just a piece of a fish head. All those
stuff. You have to be more complicated.
Like a Fox is probably his giant
not going to be hungry enough.
He's not just going to come
in for a piece of rotten meat.
There's gotta be something. It's like
says to him like what, what in the world?
What in the world could that be now?
What do you say to, I mean you're,
you're saying this all very pragmatic.
Obviously you grew up this
way and this is, you know,
just part of life and it makes sense
to me. I have no arguments with it,
but a lot of people would
submit for shooting cats.
A lot of people would be like,
you know,
you fucking piece of shit
out there shooting cats.
Like that's a weird
conversation to it is man.
And I know and the only way to treat
it like don't think for a second that I
don't recognize that that's
like something that would,
would potentially curl someone's hair.
You know,
it's going to get their attention.
But there's no other real way for me to
discuss it because at the time that it
was occurring, it was just a
matter of fact thing that happened.
And still now if I would never,
like we bring, I don't know,
I can't remember how many million,
37 million.
I don't know how million cats get
euthanized in humane society facilities in
various facilities around the country
year in another. We're fine with that.
Yeah, it's in the millions. So your,
so if you have a dairy farmer and he
just gets to a point where he has cats as
part of his business and is part of it,
you just enjoys them around and he gets
to a point where he has to get rid of
some that there's sickness
spreading among them.
I just don't really know that he's being
that absurd or that unethical did he
has someone come out and put
them down with a firearm?
I mean it's like as much
as I recognize that,
that it's so far removed from what
most people are familiar with.
It was just something that happened.
It was something I did and it's not
something that I in any way feel like I
should apologize for
because looking back on it,
it's probably still going on right now.
There's probably,
there's like a guy who can't have
that many cats running around.
Well not only that, I mean cats, cats
do transmit a lot of fucking diseases,
especially feral cats,
feral cats or that can be dangerous to
your actual humans and especially babies,
you know the cat diseases.
Like that's the reason why they tell
women not to fuck with litter when you're
pregnant again.
And also like my kid has a sandbox and
we got it covered up to keep cats of it.
So you know, I get all that.
And Dirty Brooklyn cats.
It's just something,
yeah,
it's just something I know
you can imagine what they are.
All Brooklyn cats must be fucking
terrifying. So the other thing is,
is still like if I was out now,
like
if I'm out now,
I don't have happy feelings toward a feral
cat who's out living as a Predator on
the area.
I don't feel that way about a feral cat
that I would feel about a native Redd
Foxx.
I see her date of Redd Foxx.
I feel blessed to have seen it because
I'm seeing some like cool animals. Yeah.
Like some part of a living landscape.
You know,
if I see a cat I'm like oh there's some
thing that we sort of through our own
stupidity have just yet one more thing
that we've thrust upon their assholes
thrust upon the environment.
Cause cause you can't snuggle them.
You can't call him, you can't go and pet
up feral cat, they don't protect you up.
They don't pursue it a little, scratch
it. So no, I don't have a lot of things.
But yeah of course it's a outlandish
thing and I'll sometimes do outlandish
things and half of the reason we were
to another that we talked the night,
it's like I went to Vietnam
and did a magazine story about,
about eating dog meat, you know, and I
eat dog meet seven nights in a row. Whoa.
Largely yes.
When I went there honestly I was curious
about why do people eat dog meat at the
end of the lunar year?
It's like considered a lucky
food and auspicious food
and it's cultural. Nothing,
not so fucking lucky. And I will say
they might want to try to do trinkets.
So dog, but party wanted to go there just
because I knew that it would like that.
It would like raise people's hackles,
raised my raise, my hackles. I didn't,
I didn't enjoy it. But have your tastes
do things. I couldn't tell you man.
I never enjoyed a bite of it.
I it seven nights in row and I
could never get over the moral.
I couldn't ever get over the it and then
I wished that I was man enough or like,
like collected mentally enough
to get over it and just enjoy it.
But I could never get beyond.
So you were sick every time he
ate my wife, my wife's with me,
she came out to cheat it. Oh yeah.
She never liked it. My brother Dan,
he was with me. He never liked it.
Wow. None of us could get past it.
Dogs are too cool, man. There's a deal
that they've made. But then again,
feral dogs, man, there was a
problem in Georgia recently. A,
an elderly couple was attacked and
killed by feral dogs. Really? Yeah.
They're getting,
they're getting problems in places where
you have large populations of feral
dogs. And get together as packs, you
know, meeting people killed by dogs. Man.
It's not, it's not a, if
it grows wild out there,
it's a wild animal. I mean it's that
quick. It makes the jump. Yeah, fair.
Like the whole,
the whole feral issue too,
like fascinating feral pigs and
they change the morph as feral pigs,
things playing that cause a
lot of people don't even know.
Point feral pigs are
probably might be recognized.
I mean in some places they are recognized
as they're like here now. But no,
I mean we have feral two types of feral
pigs historically that came in the US.
Do you have farm pigs that
people brought here? You know,
just the very early stages
of our national development.
People bring like agricultural breeds of
pigs and rather than feeding them you'd
kind of let them wander around and he'd
go out and forage and eat acorns one not.
And when you want him to go shoot them
and inevitably there's a certain amount
of loss.
Like some of them don't come back and
they go off into the hinterlands and make
their own way.
So then that's like a d escaped
domestic like on this feral.
Another thing we have here in the u s in
some places where people actually took
the, like all like pigs historically
are descendants of Eurasian wild boar.
So domestic breeds were
spun off of this species of,
of, of forest forest dwelling
pig lives in Europe and Asia.
The same way like candle came from
the oryx but the oryx went extinct.
Pigs came from the erasion
wild boar with the erasion.
Wild boar never went extinct.
They still exist.
People will now and then get their hands
on your Asian wild boars and think this
would be sweet if it lived in the woods
by my house and they'll take them here
and let them go. So you're taking like a
wild animal and turning it loose. Wild.
This is illegal now, but it, it went
on and in a lot of places, you know,
in some places you'll have where it's
like, that's how you get Hogzilla. No,
you get Hogzilla by taking a pig and put
into Penn and fattening it up till it's
really huge.
And then letting it go and shooting it
and calling the newspaper and saying,
you just shot in 1100 pound wild pig.
Really? That's all those, listen,
those guys that killed was
1100 pound pigs. Like one guy,
I remember it came up and he killed one
and a couple days later a guy came out
and said, I just sold that guy, that pig.
Whoa. But I thought that Hog Zillow has
been proven to be half a bore. It's um,
yeah, it's your, it's right
here. It's a male hybrid.
It's a hybrid of a wild hog and domestic
pig that was shot and killed and
Atlanta, Georgia or
excuse me, I'll lap Aha.
Georgia on June 17 2004 it
mean, I mean it was, but it,
it had been feeding on
green, but it's a, it's a
hybrid. It's half wild boar.
But here, so this guy I
need to know you need, yeah,
there was lying going on but it
has like the giant tusks and shit.
We need to allow me to
finish what I'm saying. Okay.
In some places you still have remnants
of actual Eurasia and wild pigs in the u
s right.
In some places you have some area where
all the pigs are like a farm breed,
but usually in any place
that would support one would
support other and has had
chances to support the other.
And so you have like hybrid populations,
so where eye on them. In
northern California they
tend to be black, big toss.
Why are you here? They tend to look
like a razorback your rage and pig,
but at the same time all of a sudden
you look in, one will be modeled,
he'll have like a white patch on his rump
and so you know there's some exchange
going on between what you know that when
you take a domestic pig and you said it
pharaoh, within three weeks they start to
change. They metamorphosized they there.
They're there for gets thicker and darker.
Their tusks grow.
There are the only animal that we've ever
observed that you let it loose in the
wild and it's does physical body
changes growing woolly? Yeah.
Were you aware of this?
They're nose is stretch out.
They literally become more work or wow.
I've heard they have like they'll go
through morphological changes once they,
once they changed their habits and I
guess that you might look at a person and
say the same thing that I liked this man.
Look at that motherfucker.
I mean come on dude, that was, that
was in someone's yard. I don't want to,
I don't want to get into, I don't
want to get into specifics with you,
but if you do a small amount
of research on this subject,
you're going to find that there
is a lot of fuckery. Yeah,
there's a lot of bullshit or oh,
I was around in the hog Zillow thing.
Namely that pigs that are being presented
to the press as being wild pigs in
fact have a history of
being fed artificially.
Brion pull up that picture.
Well that shit up and put it on Twitter
because that is the most ridiculous shit
in my life right there.
Why don't you just put it up on Youtube?
Look at the size of that God damn thing.
Look at that. That's a monster, man.
There's also, there's also a photography
trick called force perspective course.
The guys behind the ducting. I get
that, but Jesus Christ, that's a,
that's a crazy looking fucking
unjust to werewolf pig. Listen,
I'm not angling this not a huge pig.
I'm just saying that you have to fleas.
I do lists. I believe you, man. You're so,
you're saying that the only way you get
a pig like this as if you grow it in
captivity, do they grow hybrids in
captivity? Is that as well? They do that.
They grow up.
I know a guy that has pigs,
he has hybrid pigs and he sells
in the market, so he grows up.
There's no looks like nothing against it.
They look like this and he gets them
all giant and then he shoots him and he
left. He does calls the news
like that. I think that,
I think that what you're looking
at is when someone presents,
like let's say you raise up a pig
that gets to a thousand pounds,
that's a feat in and of itself.
It's a giant pig to sweeten the deal,
one to act like you also shot it hunting.
Who by the way,
that photo that we just said I should
correct myself right now that is actually
a wild boar that the guy shot
in Europe, so it is a wild boar.
It's nothing to do with America.
That one animal that we were just looking
at because I just googled Hogzilla and
that pulled up, which looks very
different than this Hogzilla,
which is actually a very good point.
If you see this is the Hogzilla
that was the famous one that uh,
a lot of people were saying. We're very
different looking at him and hanging out.
I think that's the one that had been
hanging out eating corn as some kind of
fattening facility,
very different looking animal.
Then the thing that we just saw,
which was really a wild
monster fucking Werewolf,
it looks like a Goddamn Werewolf.
They get bit. How did we even
get out of the subjective, like a
what? Feral pigs? Feral
animals. Feral cats.
We were talking about that they had a
feral cat for a pet. Once they're there.
Wild Man. They're not
like a writer. You mean?
You can't even think
of it as a regular cat.
You might just have while have a
fucking sewer rat as your friend,
you know they're feral cats or cranes.
They never get it out of their head.
We had a,
we had a cat named fig.
The cat that we found in the wet will be
kind of tamed it by putting fish heads
out for it and eventually kind attained
it, but you never really own that.
I had one named Jack Dempsey.
He couldn't pick this one of fucker up.
He would fucking go crazy and call your
face off, but you could go up to him,
sneak up on them and prep them a little
bit. Who let you pet them? A little bit.
Only me. It was only one
person that could pet them.
The early about this cat food. The cat
is, he would go away on long trips. Oh,
come back. A week later he come right
down to step two feral cats, man.
Like do crazy shit
steps that led from the
road down these long,
like kind of like long terrorists steps
down to our house by the lake and some
of it when he came home he'd
come right down to steps. Man,
he would walk into grass. He's like he
wanting to announce his return and then
relax and you'd get geared
up for his next trip.
I've read about a feral cat that
traveled some insane amount of distance,
like a thousand miles to reunite
with his family. Once they moved,
they move at Jay showed up. Now it
sounds like it would be, but no,
I'm pretty sure it really happened. I'm
pretty sure Google that shit. Oh No.
I want it. Here's what I was
going to get at with feral stuff,
and this is a,
this is a interesting thing is like you
look at in the Hawaiian Hawaiian islands
where you have humans,
like the Polynesians arrived in
Hawaiian that maybe 1100 years ago.
Until then there had been no
one on those islands. Right.
And they brought with
them pigs. Yeah. Okay.
At this point now we all accept that
that's like the native indigenous
population of humans.
We call them Hawaiians,
but places like the Nature Conservancy
will get their hands on land there and
they want an extra pate.
The non native wild pigs,
even though the two things
arrived together, one's native in,
one's a nonnative nuisance and it
really draws into question our ideas of,
especially now where so much everything
we eat essentially is large and imported.
I mean important like the seeds are
developed and other continents and we have
made a real melting pot of,
of what's indigenous in endemic
to here and what we've all in.
And
so my perspective on, oh there's
a cat, he don't belong here. Bang.
The fact that that camp might be
standing out in a wheat field,
which is non native plant. I don't
then look at it and go like, oh,
the whole world's cockeyed.
I'm just like very selective in what
I think should be introduced and what
shouldn't be introduced.
You know
you're engrossed in your
Hogzilla sir. No, no.
I'm listening to you totally as well.
I'm just listening to find out if I'm
full of shit about cats traveling to the
new houses. Apparently they can't do it.
Thousand Miles can find people know it's,
you know, there's a bunch
of, unfortunately a lot of
its urban myth, but how long,
but they are saying that it is a really
kind of shock. Shocking how, wow.
How far they can travel and find people.
And there's a bizarre theory about it by
this guy named Doctor Rupert Sheldrake.
It's about morphic fields and it's
actually a very hotly contested,
but in,
in his eyes,
provable that animals know when
their parents are coming home,
they know when their owners are coming
home and that they can sense it.
Even if it's a random time during the day.
There's very specific things that
the dogs do like go towards the door,
the door when they could have no idea
that the person was anywhere near them.
Yeah,
I actually see it all the time.
I cause I have security systems and like
I can watch the recording video maybe
five minutes before I get home that dog
or in cats would just suddenly kind of
wake up and kind of like just look out,
like look towards the window and
it's like not even like 40 minutes.
Sheldrake's idea about it is that there's,
there's some other sense that
we don't particularly have.
There's something that we don't use.
We don't need it so we don't detect it.
And there's a,
there's a field of energy that somehow
or another we can detect certain things
with and we're just not in tune with it.
And one of the best ways of proving this
is the one psychic thing that seems to
be measurable and that is that people
know when people are looking at them and
that's a,
Oh actually I got to show
that statistically measurable
that people can tell
when people are looking at them. And the
idea behind this is there's some, some,
some energy that's going out and
something that people were tuning in.
But you know, we, we poo
poo it because it's not a
commonplace idea, but what it's,
you know,
smell crazy as hell.
The idea that there's something that
you can't see and it comes from us,
a cheeseburger and it goes
up your nostrils and it's,
he's Adams and let you know it's delicious
or that it smells like shit and you
should leave it alone and run from it. I
mean, just try describing what that is,
you know, I mean, it's not like arrogant
enough to be able to say like, oh no,
the world stops right here.
Like whatever I'm privy to is the end
and nothing else can be privy to anything
extra than what I am. I mean, this is kind
of a ridiculous notion. Like it's hard.
It's impossible to say what kind
of trip animals around animals.
You see animals do inexplicably things
and I don't then wind up turning to like
mysticism or like spiritual isn't to
explain it when it might just be that they
have sensory there.
They have like sensory perceptions that
are picking up on things that allude me.
But you spent a lot of time
in Alaska. Um, have you uh,
ever heard a legitimate foot story?
You ever heard some that
make you really think
a really weird thing to talk about it?
No,
it's not what we're doing to talk about
and not, not taking a dead, not serious.
Okay. No, no. There was no rushing.
I does it.
Here's the one of the,
I mean there's a million reasons
why I don't know, a million.
It was a handful of reasons why I'm,
I'm very suspicious of big for stories
and don't believe in big foot and primary.
I think about like this if even if
you have a very small population,
things like think of the Florida panthers,
there's a subspecies of the
mountain liner. Peugeot,
500 of them live in Florida,
right? Yeah. Yeah. Every year.
The edit time they were down in the last
50 or 500 no, there's about 50 yeah.
Yeah. I got hit by, it was a five.
You get hit by cars. Fuck them.
No what I'm saying or not. Again,
you have so few and you got,
they'll get hit by a car,
they'll turn up in a guy's yard.
It's like you can't hide them.
Right.
And then you're telling me that we've
had over all these hundreds of years,
no Harry and the Hendersons
moment where a got that we,
there's just not like a dead
one floats up on the beach.
A guy runs one over with a car.
It's like you really can't hide animals.
You knew that.
You take like a handful of wolves
and reintroduce them somewhere like
Yellowstone national park,
the greater Yellowstone ecosystem,
one of the wildest
sections of our country.
You turn a handful of wolves in there.
It's not two days later and you know
you got one shot, one, some guy ran,
went over.
It's like things just kind of come out
of the woodwork and I don't think that we
could have been hiding this giant primate
out there without someone
hitting it with a car,
without having just like you and I know
that the older they got like a top of
one's head here and to track
there and the Yeti. Yeah.
It never got an actual physical specimen
of a big foot, you know, Mitch Hedberg,
uh, he fell as though pictures
of big foot weren't blurs,
just a big foot was blurred. Yeah, that
was a great job. I remember that. Um,
less drought had a great big foot story,
you know, survivor man, it's fucking,
you know, it w he was talking about
being up in Alaska completely by himself,
hundreds of miles from anything.
And he heard,
he heard like some crazy primates
sound and something small branches.
Well he was alone in the
dark, you know, in Alaska.
But the whole Alaska big foot things
brand new. No, it's not now. There's bad.
It is. There's been a lot of like BC,
Alaska stuff like British Columbia. Yeah.
Like British Columbia has got
like a big like mean brand new,
but like the last 20 years like
I don't like, there's not like a,
like you don't like native Alaskans don't
have an oral history that I know of of
big foot's the way magic north Pacific
northwest is where it seems that those
legends came from,
I was like Pacific northwest had an oral
history and all of of this occurrence
and it was something they
discussed and it was,
it was part of their mythology
and legends and explanations,
but now it's like all
this big in Michigan's
upper peninsula, you know, like
every state has its own big foot's.
Ohio has big feet.
Those it is that the portal and Laskin
bigfoot was created by hallmark. Actually
the idea, I believe shit man, it really
bullshit. The idea would be Alaska.
You think? It's not the only reason why
I say I leave, I leave everything open.
The only reason why I leave
everything open all the time,
but very rarely why believe in
one way or another back door.
I know what you're saying and believing
that shits on don't get past the velvet
rope. I believe in I, there's,
you know, you have to,
I have to really absolutely know
that something's true or not true.
And one of the reasons why I
think it's a fascinating subject,
it's because they know what it
actually used to be an animal.
There's a thing called the gigantic
Pythagoras age. I think that's what it is.
I don't think,
I think the original big foot was that
just some stone guys in the 70s that
tried to, you know, take a photo of
it. It could have been done. Well,
the only reason why
that doesn't make sense,
because the native Americans have over
250 different names for a large man,
hairy ape thing that lives in the woods.
If it was an intelligent priming,
it could avoid the bolt.
But it's the thing that's created
again and again,
like I was in the Philippines and
they're born in the Philippines,
out in the jungle.
They had a thing like an equivalent beast.
I think we all are swaying.
It was like the os weighing or ASW a
and g and it would like tear you up very
various ways. We all have this inherent
fear of the unknown and the dark.
Just from back in the days when we really
hadn't taken an audit of every plant,
every animal there was on the earth.
And so there was always legends
and worries and you know,
the North American Indians only had their
self to go on and who knows? You know,
you see a fucking grizzly
bear standing up on its back,
feet in the middle of the woods at dusk
from a distance and you fucking shit
your pants and run away. You
could convince yourself, you know,
if you were tall storyteller or you know,
didn't have the best grasp on reality,
you can convince yourself you saw a giant
man. So you're seeing things that dark.
It's very possible.
The only reason why I leave it
open and I don't have an opinion.
If I had a bet money,
I would say there's probably no big foot,
but I would be happy if I lost. I'd be
like excited are sexy if they would.
Actually be elated. And, and you said
earlier, like you said, like the reason
you find it fascinating,
my thinking that, you know,
putting my money on the fact that it
doesn't exist like very emphatically.
Does it then make me think that
the idea of it is it fat is fair.
I mean the idea of it is
fascinating.
Hoaxing is so complex.
If it is just hoaxing cause they've found
dermal ridges on um, on, on footprints,
which actually indicate
that there's a print,
like a fingerprint that's coming
off the toe was like, man,
if that's all hoaxing it's so elaborate.
It's really fascinating.
This Green Lane happen,
you know, I mean if you spend
any amount of time, and again I,
I can't like attack specific examples.
Like, I'm not, I'm not a quick to do that,
but I know that if you spend any amount
of time looking at sign animal sign in
the woods, evidence of animals
in the woods tracks things,
they leave a confused record
and and things, you know,
animals put their feet down a ways and
turning things on certain surfaces and do
certain things where you wind up with
strange tracks and sometimes her and shit
like just,
and sometimes other sets of circumstances
will create things that you would
swear it would be prints in the
ground or you know. But again, I,
I can't like comment a specific examples.
I know what you're saying.
It's not like,
like the,
the record of an animal's passing
through mud and snow and sand and things.
It is often quite confused.
It can be very difficult to sort it out
and you'll look at something that you
swear might be a track and you examine
it and then winds up not being attracted
to. It could just be a bear
and some slippery surface.
And the bear puts his paw down in the
mud slips and it looks like a giant
footprint. It could be
something like that. It could
be some guys screwing around.
Yeah, it could be all the above.
Right to be that as well. And if you,
you know when you take into account like
just Imana hoaxing that goes down with
archeological specimens,
people have a motivation beyond,
it's like whatever kind of money they
make off it just to be just to do it.
There's a guy like that used to fake
retired about early forms of arrowheads.
There's like a type of arrowhead,
a very old type of Harold
had called a full point.
There's this guy that was by last name,
McCormick
spent like devoted his life to like
making fake fake Folsom and spinning them
off to museums but not
even profiting on it.
Just like try to be like Douche
bags on another one. He just really,
and now he was so good that it's now
cool if you own a McCormick. It's cool.
You really,
yeah.
It'd be like if you imagine you got
made like really great fake Rembrandt's
later. People are. I'd be
like, it's not a Rembrandt,
but it's actually this
guy that made some sweet,
fake Rembrandts and he became like Banksy,
the Banksia Rembrandt's. Who's Banksy?
Really? You never heard of that guy?
He's a famous graffiti artists. No, no,
never heard of the movie called
exit through the gift shop.
You got to Netflix at one really
fascinating, fascinating, very famous,
very, very talented graffiti
artists. No Man. You know,
I'll tell you something about me.
When someone tells me to watch a movie,
you don't want to watch it?
No, I watch it. Really if,
unless it's someone telling
me like grizzly man, y'all,
one of the best isn't one of the
greatest movies of all time is one of my
favorite documents, but I watched it
again the other day, all Herzog stuff.
Not all of it, but I didn't like
that. The cave one was kind of dry,
but I was like, I don't know how you could
make a bad move about cave paintings.
What? He managed to do it, man,
it was really weird. Right?
I mean it was like almost like his
reverence was annoying. Look at the abuse.
I wanted a little more like, I
want a little more like, well,
so what is up with the cave paintings?
Not from your like dream perspective,
but can we get like an expert in here to
talk about these firms? Yeah, exactly.
Well we had a guy in here that was talking
about some of the first works of art,
you know the first things that men
worshiped and then it made sense that the
kind of worship these,
these buffalo,
they withdraw because I
was their sustenance, you
know, you know, they would,
they would have to like live
like chasing these, these,
these groups of them.
And that's how they sustain themselves
and that that's when they find this.
It's like the first evidence of idolatry.
The first evidence of
worshiping something.
But that was a trip you think about
and the cave he's talking about.
And what was it that bird bird advances
a baseball movie, wasn't it? What was,
what's her name? What's the name of the
movie? Cave of dreams Cave of forgotten.
Oh, the Werner Herzog movies.
And we were saying, yeah, it was,
I don't remember the name of a
cave of forgotten dreams cave of,
hold on a second. I'll,
I'll, if you draw it.
So cave, right? Yeah.
You remember. See Dog,
why are you looking at it up
cave of forgotten dreams. Okay.
So how do you know what the Hell is Tom?
Oh No.
Oh that set back the clock on,
on elaborate painting
by thousands of years.
But I remember reading at one point,
something that I even like later summarize
this argument in the book is that
cave paintings that someone used to
have put forth this theory that cave
paintings really proliferating at a
period when you were seeing that all that
megafauna vanishing, you know, all the
animals that went extinct the ice age,
but like,
it seemed that as they were vanishing,
people started to replicate them
in art. You know, that makes sense.
You're seeing the changing of time
and you're summoning them in some way.
Are they aware of this new
discoveries that they've, uh,
they've found out that our answers,
our ancestors had mastered deep
sea fishing 42,000 years ago.
They found evidence of tuna,
they found tuna bones and they
found hooks and lines, whereas that,
this is in, I'll tell you
right now, East Timor,
north of north of Australia,
which contains the bones
of more than 2,800 fish,
some of them were caught as
long as 42,000 years ago. Yeah.
And this is deep sea fishing.
They found the world's or,
or earliest recorded fish hook made of
Shell and dating from between 23,000 and
16,000 years ago. That's good
stuff. That's amazing. So they had,
they had been ocean bound, not just,
not just like shooting it from the bank,
but they went into deep water and somehow
or another had enough line to pull a
fucking tuna out of hundreds
of feet of water like that.
They must have made their own
twine and they must have, you know,
braided it together and made a fucking,
you'll know deep sea fishing.
You just, cause you're
in deep water. I mean,
tuner generally fish very near to
surface. So there is way the hell out. Oh,
I see what you're saying. They're way the
hell out catching tuna at the surface.
So, okay, so they don't need some,
a lot of line man. I mean, you're
strong as fuck to get a pull a man.
You'd have to play him a little bit. No,
no, I'm not. That's an impressive stuff.
And I have known now and I like to
know that kind of thing. Know this.
This was a really recent discovery.
This is a date dated November 25th,
uh, from the UK mail online and it's,
you know, it's got the photographs of it
and everything. It's really,
really fascinating. The, the
site where they found it,
it's a, that's a, that's a
pretty intense discovery.
And there they were always pushing
back. I mean, on a regular basis,
pushing back the date when people
figure things out, moving it back,
and then sometimes moving it forward.
The thing that gets moved back here is,
is we constantly read,
are readjusting how long people have
been here in North America has come and
gone.
You know,
the one thing that they figured out is
that it's really one of the most shocking
things is that 10,000 years ago, half
of it was covered by over a mile of ice.
That's just 10,000 years ago.
I mean,
that's really amazing when you stop
and think about it. Like when my,
my home state was drowned,
man,
I'm sure when you think about
people coming here from,
from Europe where things have existed in
the, in a pretty static state for far,
far longer, and people have
been there for far for them.
When they first came over here,
man, there was just, you know,
scattered tribes of native Americans.
But what a crazy find, you know,
this one continent or there's
hardly anybody there. I mean,
how many Indians were there with her? 1
million over the entire continent. No,
I think there are many more, but many
more than a million. Yeah, but 90% I mean,
you know, it could have been
populations at 10 million.
Some people even say it's 10 million.
That's Miami.
Is You lost immediately relevant.
I mean, fairly immediate.
You lost to infectious disease
giant 100% of the population. Wow.
So a lot of the time when
guys are talking, like when,
when you're looking at,
you know, like Lewis and Clark or
we've talked about them earlier,
they come up the Missouri and they
come across as like abandoned village.
It's like, oh, where'd everybody go? I
mean they're all done and they're like,
no one's here. And there's
all these, you know,
there's all those buffalo and no
one's hunting them in. It's crazy.
But what they don't know, as
you know, 40 years earlier,
a smallpox epidemic slept through there
and just carry it off. 90% of the people.
And so because disease would
travel faster than individuals.
Like you had like what Cabeza de Vaca.
He,
he was the first guy to kind of walk
along the Gulf coast and the early 1500
then there's an absence of people and in,
in,
in Coronado goes up in air
and that amount of time,
just massive amounts of people were
carried off cause disease always traveled
faster than that's taking away from
the atrocities that were, you know,
purposely committed on native.
Like the actual,
the actual slaughter of people paled
in comparison to the nothing to the
disease. I mean disease
was like disease. I mean,
I mean this is the stuff that I'm,
this is the outcome.
It was by mean people generally accept
the figure is somewhere around 90% of the
people were carried off by infectious
disease shit. And it's just what you were,
they had never hear that because
when you pat, when you pass through,
so you had very small numbers
of individuals passing
through very cold climates
and the way to come here and they'd just
arrived here without infectious disease.
They had some stuff,
like there's debates about what
exact sexually transmitted diseases,
they add those dirty bitches, but that's
what it was not have, but not having, um,
you know, like influenza, all that
stuff we just left behind.
And it's amazing.
And it's what we were
talking about earlier,
how you go to a new place and you
drink the water and everyone else,
there's norm. It's normal
to them. They're used to it.
They've developed an immunity to it and
the ones that can't hack it died a long
time ago. But it's incredible when you
think about the timeframe that this entire
continent was covered in
ice than the ice thaws out.
Some people are there,
then new ones come in boats.
Then the whole thing fucking changes. And
it's like, what a short amount of time.
I mean,
what an amazingly short amount of time
to just completely transform an entire
continent. That's one of the reasons
I'm interested in deep history here.
Um, as, I mean, besides the fact that
I live here, but it's, it's more,
it's easier to grasp because
things happened like, like Africa.
You can't even begin to get your
head around human history in Africa.
It's monkeys because there was no,
to turn into a smarter must know
beginning point, it wasn't being like,
I don't know at what point do we call
it Lucy it, when is it a human here?
It's like no one day,
right?
One day, not long ago in
a historical sense. Uh,
dude and his wife and his family
step foot on this thing and enables
and they found and this and then rate
the pill is just breaking them away. The,
you know, a lot of people
have these nostalgic ideas
about what the settlers did,
but if you read some of the accounts
from, from what Columbus is, people did,
they did horrific, horrific things to the
native Americans that were here. It's a,
it's amazing how horrific things of
that. I mean, it's like each other. Well,
the Lakota,
Lakota people were not known as Lakota
people that are known as the Su Su.
It means enemy. That's what
they called them. Everybody.
They called themselves a Lakota people,
but the other Indians that they would rape
and murder, they called them sue. Yeah,
they weren't,
I mean they were living a pure existence
in the sense of they were living off
the land. They killed a buffalo. They used
every single part of that, that Buffalo,
they date. There was no
waste tribal. That's a hotly
contested thing, is it really?
Well, I think wasn't their ethics in that
wasn't there, that happened at times. Uh,
I say fine.
Where you'll find like digs at cliff's
sites where they might've run 800 animals
off a cliff and they find that
the only, the only like, you know,
a dozen of the carcasses wherever just
articulated, ever caught up. Well,
might be one of those situations
where he got to do what you gotta do,
chasing a bunch of Buffalo. It
was off the cliff. It wasn't a,
it wasn't a crime like weight.
And there's a lot of things like that.
I remember outside of this fort and
South Dakota one time they killed 1300,
just cut the tongue's out. Wow. But why?
To sell them tongues, you're
worth a lot of money. You get,
I at a time you get like a buck form.
They traded him for bat for whiskey
and drank it and Jesus Christ,
I left the hides and we
left and left everything.
But there's two things going on there.
One, there was already a corruption of,
of alcohol and almost
like a purposeful giving,
like a purposeful addiction to people by
like trading alcohol and do. Um, they're,
the ones going on is when people were
wasting those huge Mazda animals.
Like we now think of it as waste,
but they did probably didn't even
have a concept of finiteness. Right.
It was like they had no idea we could
run something. Yeah, you like use,
you treat it with respect by using
what you need at that given time.
And if you follow this very
elaborate set of codes and taboos in,
in, in, in practices,
you have your certain that you'll be able
to live this lifestyle into perpetuity.
And if that means that if you one day
kill a buffalo to celebrate and you just
cut out its tongue and its liver and
you have a celebration and walk off the
next day,
it wasn't that you just committed a crime.
I see.
And by the way,
that is going to get eaten
by other animals and bacteria
and nature's can absorb
it back into the earth.
But you're right,
like what you brought up is there is
this tendency to really celebrate these
things and, and it, it frustrates me now
when people act like that, we've, like,
we as people are,
have become so violent now and it's like
violence touches a smaller percentage
of our lives now than ever.
The fact that you can get to be that,
I know people who've gotten to be in their
late thirties have never laid eyes on
a dead person.
Yeah.
Would have been impossible.
It's like unheard of and they
must not have email, right.
There's no way they have an internet
connection and never even looked at
someone's going to send
them some dead people.
You can just look it up and just
send them to you, man. People,
if you have friends,
hey, check out this guy,
they're going to send it ups and
they're gonna send you a video of a dude
getting run over by a truck or something.
But
I see the easiest time of human history
for sure. Less violent, the least violent.
I think it's like pretty gravy.
We have such a, like a, you know,
maturing sense of morality.
That's awesome because we're aware that
we don't need to be in Iraq blowing
things up. So the fact that
this is happening and it's
so unjustified and it's so
ridiculous and there's so much information
that shows like very clearly that
it's all been done under the auspices of
lies and bullshit that, you know, it's,
it's, it's offensive to people that
that exists in this day and age.
So that's why people run up and say,
well,
there's so much war and it's so much
violence and it's so ridiculous and we're
so doomed.
They're right.
But in perspective to the
history of the human race there,
they're not really, right.
It's a pretty cushy time.
As long as you're not in the more zone.
Yeah,
because,
well I think that's the
thing about violence is is
so you know it's so focalized
now and little spots, but you look
at these areas we're talking about.
I think that violence used
to be just omnipresent. Yeah.
Like you know like here in town,
like out of the La Brea tar pits,
like one human body came
out of the La Brea tar pits.
It was like a woman from 9,000 years
ago who had been struck in the head with
some kind of Tomahawk object.
The guy can work man who comes out of
the Columbia River from sometime around.
Then he's got an Arrow
head buried in them.
That guy they pull out of the
Italian Alps from 7,000 years ago.
He's got two Arrow heads buried in
them. Yeah. It's like you can't, Yup.
If you find like an,
you can't find the old skeleton that old
and pulled up without having to be that
this guy had been mixing it up with
other people in a highly violent, yeah.
It's funny because the older pro,
the primates go,
the more they have marks on him from
big cats and as they get more and more
modern, they're, they're fucked up by
humans. Yeah. The ice man. Right. He'd,
he'd been, he'd been fucked up a couple
of times. Right. The cat though, man,
he made some sweet stuff to his shoes
are made out of a variety of different
leathers and insulate boss.
He was bad. Amazing. Fine.
If I could hang out with any guy,
like if people said,
if you could hang out with anyone
alive or dead, it would be the ice man.
That guy, I would love old. Was He when?
When the weight is seven seven
thousand seven thousand years ago. Wow.
He was tattooed 7,000 years ago.
People lived like that.
It's a little bit of goddamn blink of an
eye. Right. His name is [inaudible] Uzi.
Yeah. That's what they type
it in. You don't know what
his real fucking mammos no,
they gave him a handle.
I guy was a bad ass though.
That's a real hunter right there.
Yeah.
Or he didn't Hunt Highway Z. Otz. Yeah,
he didn't have high highwire they'll
highway or offensive for that dude.
He's fair. Chase. How do you feel
about, I know there's a big issue.
I believe it's an Idaho on the
introduction of a Canadian wolves,
those big ass fucking giant gray wolves.
And they're like,
currently it's a reintroduction,
but there are different types of Wolf.
It's a different species than the
native wolf. There are native timber,
timber will like gray wolf,
timber wolves. It's the same wall.
So why are they so small and
Idaho and they're so big,
the ones that come from
Canada because they, you know,
one thing you wind up
with is, well, you know,
you had the red wolf down
small in New Mexico. Yeah,
but I mean generally mammals tend to be
much bigger at the northern end of their
range. So you look at a mature
deer in Alberta, he's going to be,
you ain't might be 250 pounds.
You take the same species,
deer in Florida and he's going to
be a hundred pounds. And she's like,
mammals are always bigger at the northern
end of the extreme because what you
wind up having is you have less surface
area and it's easier for them to retain
more. If you have more surface area,
it's easier to get rid of warmth,
so the fact that you're pulling like the,
you might go get some big ass wolves out
of northern Canada and bring them in.
I don't think that's the issue
of them being different sides.
It's all the same species.
It's a gray wolf. Oh,
I support both the reintroduction of
wolves and I support the eventual control
through hunting of those wolves.
They're already hunting them.
There's a picture of this check with
this giant fucking Wolf that she shot.
They're a huge man. Yeah. Then
another big critters take names.
That's like a very like that
right there is one of the,
you know in like and hunting and
conservation issues and ethics issues.
The debate about what to do about these
wolves, but this one woman in this photo,
this one right here,
and see this fit.
Their official stories at the wolf was
running up to attack this woman and she
had a of Bose down, shot it with
a handgun. Here's the thing,
I'm not looking at your computer,
but you have to, I trust you.
You're a little more cautious than to
just start typing stuff in and balls show.
She could be full of Shit and she
could've been out there poaching.
And
besides, there is a wolf season
going on right now. There,
there is some, there was wolf hunting
going on this fall and winter in,
in a number of western states.
And,
oh, wait a minute. Here's a
store. This is really interesting.
Is this from the outfitter?
Listen, let me tell you this.
He took a group of nine out of state
elk archery hunters from the Great Lakes
region. They ended up calling a pack
of 17 wolves by elk cow calling. Oh,
there you go.
Big Ass fucking group of wolves.
And none of the hunters had a side arm
or a wolf tag and it was a very traumatic
experience that will surrounded
them. It says all of the hunters, uh,
went home early,
very disturbed,
claiming these wolves were very
different from the Great Lakes wolves.
These Idaho Wolves actually hunt
you and they're not afraid of you.
None of that. No one's
been, they had a documented,
the first documented wolf kill in decades
in Alaska and one woman. They've never,
anyone who's afraid of wolves is
just a pussy. Who's afraid of stuff?
Wait a minute of wolf killed a woman.
You have one person. Like what?
How often
we'll come in contact with wool.
Well you know when we got killed by
coyotes in Canada a couple of years ago,
well it looks like people like
people get killed by some of the,
probably got killed by domestic dogs. But
I mean like if you're afraid of wolves,
it's like I would suggest like those
guys and it's too bad they're from the
Great Lakes State.
Cause that's my home area.
I would tell those guys the
day are some of the law, the,
I'm glad they're not in the woods anymore.
If you would actually leave because of
some wolves. Well there's so big man.
Look at the size of this photo. It's
big. You've seen that, that wolf. Oh,
you know what? You know what that,
that won't, let me see that picture.
I think you're looking at it
online at hoax. That photo.
That's a that that wolf was killed
in Europe. It was, yeah. That's not,
you're looking at it online.
It says a Canadian gray, 180
pound male Canadian. Yeah.
Great nod that pictures made the round
recently shot near Central Idaho.
It's horse shit that this is from the
Idaho Observer, man. Let me see this.
June, 2009 the either the Observer. Yeah.
Is it a dude holding her while dude?
Yeah.
Maybe the Idaho Observer got hoaxed
Tony, that wolf is not what you
picture has been making the rounds
from 35 transplanted specimens as of
1996 the federally reintroduced Canadian
Gray Wolves have multiplied and spread
throughout the northern two thirds of
Idaho and are decimating wild game hurts.
This nonessential program is a
complete failure according to some,
but a master stroke in a dial diabolical
federal occupational planning.
And what they're saying is that there's
more than 4,000 of these and that they
were going to let them get to a point
of a 1500 and then they were going to
start calling them.
But now it's gotten like pretty adult
Mohamed.
Here's the promise.
Nothing you're saying like nothing
you're saying is really debatable.
Those statistics and facts
minus the commentary are true.
But what you're running up against is
you're looking at a piece of propaganda
put out by a guy who's like
categorically anti wolf.
I would gather that photo you're looking
at has made the rounds and has been
attributed to being killed in a
number of states by number of people.
There was this one is the size of
that fucking thing. This got killed.
That's another one. Like, so there's
some big wolves getting killed,
but there's big wolves that
were way bigger than the
ones that were living there
when they introduced these new wolves.
These new world's got a lot bigger.
Uh, I don't, I don't think
the hunt, not packs of 20.
It's not a first name. Okay, well listen,
I, I'm out. That's why I'm asking you.
They're fucking beautiful man.
I'll tell you that.
There's a photo of some dark one. Look at
that. There's such wild looking animals,
man. Oh, the grayed out.
Incredible. Yeah. I, I had a,
a friend of mine and uh, he went and, uh,
went wolf hunting and I was like, wow,
what the fuck man,
why would you hunt wolves?
Well,
I think that we have an obligation to
try to manage a population if we have an
obligation to do like
targeted reintroductions and
things that we've extra pay
it through human use,
but I don't then think that that means
that it becomes perpetually off limits
and we can't do any management.
I mean,
we manage it by bringing it there and
I think that we need to maintain the
control on it because I don't think,
I think that we have other obligations
to other interested parties.
And to say that you're going to bring,
besides that one, there's another one is
huge. So I have the one shot and Idaho.
He's a fucking giant welds man. These
are huge, and I'm with you though,
but I think that's the important thing
is that people need to understand that
they need to be managed and
that they were brought in.
They were managed in the first place. The
whole, they didn't exist there before.
No, they did. But they were mismanaged.
I mean they, they existed there.
I would say that right in the Dick.
If I see it my backyard,
I'll tell you right now, manage
mismanaged. Fuck you. Go Fuck Yourself.
That giant ass teeth snarling.
Motherfucker was in my
backyard looking to eat me.
They were there.
We had wolves and we wiped them out
through poisoning and various uncontrolled
things like we did.
We didn't have a system in place to
preserve the resource or some people might
object to the term resource,
but we didn't have a system in place to
make a sustainable population. Later.
We tried to right that wrong by doing
reintroductions and some people have a
hard time accepting the fact that we could
make it jump from having been that we
screwed up and wipe them out.
Now we put them back and accepting the
fact that we would now make a jump to, to,
to start killing them.
Right. But, but as, as some
by the argument at all,
it's not the same breed if it is a much
larger margin wolf and a lot of people
think, and that's the stupidities,
that this is a bigger animal.
This is an animal that's
not native to this area.
The genetics are
different than the animal.
I don't think you, you know, to get
into what is a breed and a species,
it's the same I'm telling you.
Right. But there's the same species.
You might have their bigger, right.
I don't think there's any way.
There's no way to argue that because you
don't have enough specimens of old ones
to tell if they were bigger.
Now
forget what I said about not hunting
one. I want that rug. Yeah, it's nice.
It's beautiful. I need
that. Come on, man. So big,
crazy giant fucking as long
as you've found out that
wolf was a cunt. I was like,
this is one wolf. He was fucking with
all the other wolves. Nobody likes cows,
an asshole.
He's raping all the female wolves.
Nobody's going to miss that
shithead. He ate everybody sheep. So
if you have blue some houses
down, you might get some, really,
you might get some really big wolves by,
maybe you're taking some walls and
putting it in and do it like a place where
they have very little competition with
one another and they have a great food
resource and they're living to be,
uh,
an older age because there's
not predation on the wolves.
So maybe you're getting some big wolfs,
but you can't get hung up on this idea
that somehow they screwed up and brought
a bigger wolf into an area where it
didn't belong. It's like the gray wolf.
Uh Huh. Now you put those animals in
Idaho, we're getting to be about 70,
80 pounds and these walls that
they've introduced from Canada,
I get to be 200 pounds.
That's a different animal. I,
I mean,
I'm just reading what they're saying.
They're saying that this is the major
issue is that this is a larger animal is
that's not true. I'm not, you're saying
it's not animal, no matter what he does,
it's the same species.
Okay.
I'm not equipped to talk about how
big the average weight is. I have,
I don't know how anyone would really
have the data to show me what the average
weight was before wolves were extirpated
in that area and what the average way
it is now, and I don't try, and as
much as I, I've enjoyed talking to you,
I don't trust the,
the,
the random pages that you're pulling up
or really pull my information off that.
Yeah, I understand. It's,
I think that you're getting into something
that's a bit more complicated and
something that's not really easy to
pin down. Why I don't have an opinion.
There's a lot of ways there's not,
there's a lot of ways in which
you would find the animals under.
Some sets of circumstances tend
to get really big. The same way.
If you take two pigs out of the same
litter, these hogs, Zillow's right,
two brothers out of the same litter,
put one out in the wild and the arid
area and put one in a corn bin and then
tell me that the one most have been a
different species cause he got really big.
Right. I see what you're
saying. So I don't really know.
I'm not familiar with,
even though humans are humans and um,
you,
you went to Africa and you've got the
biggest people and you made them slaves
and then you brought him over here and
then you made the mate and have big,
giant babies.
Even though that that person could breed
with anyone here and they are in fact
human and of the same species. There's
no doubt genetically they're different.
They're bigger.
Sure.
There's no,
I mean there's no doubt that any
populations that have been separated for a
significant amount of
time becoming some way
genetically different. Tricky to
bring in. I mean look at this again.
I don't know nearly enough.
The only reason why I'm bringing this up
is the argument of all these anti looks.
This is the doom and gloom.
I'm scared that wolves are kind
of come get me approach. You know,
it's like these people that are
upset saying he's just some big,
I managed and they're fucking up there
and they would have preferred it.
These are big ass and they would prefer,
they brought some smaller wolves.
They would prefer that they would be
wolves that are the same size as the
indigenous was the old kind of
the walls that are still there.
They still exist tonight. Oh, they're
still native walls. They just,
these Canadian wolves. They're saying
again, this is what they're saying.
I just think, what do you, what
is your dirty hands on management?
There've been wolves that big is
that we're saying that native ones.
Uh, okay. There's two.
You have some natural reintroduction of
wolves going on in the northern rock.
What is the benefit of that? You,
well, let me, let me explain.
I'm saying there was definitely a period
of time when you were not gonna find in
the greater Yellowstone area,
for instance, wolves were
pretty much gone. However,
there's always been some number of wolves
that would drift in from Canada and
come in and maybe not have like
really established populations,
but they would come in and they would
drift out and they would come in and drift
out.
At the point of time we're in right now,
we have a lot of animals there.
There are a lot of like thriving wolf
packs in the northern Rockies that derived
from animals.
We specifically brought
in and reintroduced and
there's a lot of animals that
are probably derived from animals
that naturally drifted in from Canada.
If they're saying that somehow the ones
that were reintroduced tend to be larger
than the ones that were,
are naturally spreading out and
distributing into these areas from Canada.
I don't really know if that's really the
question we're talking about right now.
I don't know how to answer that.
I,
I'd have to look more carefully at what
you're looking at and I'd have to ask
someone who's familiar with
it in an unbiased sense.
If wolves in fact came from
this land of real big bigness.
I know that you will get for a number
of factors. You will find that bears,
for instance, bears and Pennsylvania,
black bears and Pennsylvania.
Same species is black bears in Montana,
but the ones in Pennsylvania you get way
bigger than they do in Montana. Also.
The ones in Pennsylvania
are almost invariably black.
The ones in Montana have are tend
to be chocolate, Brown and blond.
They find that if you're in a area
that has over 20 inches of rainfall,
you tend to have more jet black bears.
If they have an area with a lot of
mast like acorns and beach nuts,
they tend to get much bigger
than the area where they don't.
Bears that have access to salmon tend to
get much bigger than areas that don't.
A lot of those things are
of words they're living,
so if a bear is living in
Pennsylvania getting huge on acorns
and you bring that bear and put
them in the air environment,
he's going to change.
It's like you don't,
you don't know that he's
going to be continued to be
like to put off giant bears.
He might be taking like bears that are
genetically equal and you're putting them
in prime habitat and giving them all
the available resources they need to
achieve their maximum size.
It would make sense to me if you had an
area that had no population of wolves
and you had a population of deer and elk
who are not accustomed to predation by
wolves,
and you took some wolves from an area
where they tended to reach maximum size of
120 pounds and you introduce them
into this area and they live without
competition from other packs and they
have access to massive supplies of meat
that has no idea what they are.
And then you come and tell me that 20
years later you find that these walls that
used to be around an average of 120
pounds are now averaging 150 pounds.
I wouldn't be remotely surprised by that.
Okay. That totally makes sense to me.
And you know,
of course you always have
to throw everything through
the fearmongering filter
and everybody's worried
that the wolves are coming.
I disagree that you're a pussy if you
get killed by a wolf because one person,
no, you're not a pushing to get killed
by frank. Your Pussy. If you're afraid.
I think of your post. If you don't
go in the woods because of wolf.
Did you see the Liam Neeson trailer for
the movie? The gray surrounded by wolves,
bro.
I was supposed to review that.
I was supposed to review that moved from
outside but I could go really to the,
I could never, they could never
line up the screening Fao. Dammit.
Why would I was supposed to review it
through the Lens of how well does this
really accurately portray
wilderness last word on the subject.
What is the benefit of
bringing these wolves back?
Cause it to thin out the herds of the
benefit to bring those bulls back would be
to,
to write some of the wrongs
we've committed against
the environment and to try
to help create a intact ecosystem with
all of the players present on the land
and make things extra scary
in the woods. Yeah. If that,
if you want to go camping, he hit
you hear that shit outside your door,
sniffing your fucking tent. It separates
the men from the boys. You know?
I actually like,
I like hunting and grizzly
areas because one I like.
I like that sense of thrill.
And Pat,
you said grizzly areas meaning the bare
areas that have been around them to camp
near them? Yeah. Oh Jeez.
I liked the feeling of being near him
and I also liked that a lot of people
don't like it and you can,
you tend,
I think that it has a detectable
effect on competition.
If I had an iron man suit,
I'll go hunting,
bear with the iron man suit and
just beat the fuck out of a bear.
Do you think that's how it, that would
be the ultimate way to fight a bear?
It was a guy at an iron man. Have you
seen the grizzly project? Oh yeah,
that's right. He does have some kind
of a crazy tries to make a work.
He can't get the berries
to attack them. Yeah.
Oh, that's hilarious.
They even go out in the woods and like
shoot a horse and waiting for the bears
to hit it, and he tried to
go up and confront the bears,
but you could never get
a bear to come at him.
I lived in Colorado for a while and one
of the things in my town was a bear had
started breaking into cars
and they were telling people,
don't leave food in your car or the bear
will go in there and you would think,
well, the bear is just going to look.
There's no food. He's going to leave. No,
they eat the inside of your fucking car.
They eat everything.
They state your fucking dashboard.
Well also, if you have leather seats,
I bet it probably confuses
the shit out of them.
You hear of a eating vinyl gas cans.
Oh God,
I gotta I gotta place in Southeast Alaska
and the neighbor is telling me about a
bear that broke into a guy shed there
and ate a three gowns of gear oil.
Well, the lack of fuck, can you
imagine laptop? Fuck. Can you imagine?
What do you think came out of his
room that came out of your asshole?
Shit going 75 miles an hour
with high viscosity.
They'll fucking mobile one commercial.
Hey, by the way, it will we wait,
we only have a few minutes left. Did you
hear about seadog or moderator that, uh,
that what happened to him over no.
Thursday? No. What happened? Well,
I guess unfortunately he's been battling
a lot of depression lately and he's a,
he did suicide by cop in Glendale and uh,
I guess, uh, his, his girlfriend or
some females said that, uh, you know,
he's been trying to kill
himself. He's been, you know,
over to try and overdose
and drugs and stuff.
Then the other day something happened,
so he was like that guy that stood in
the middle of the street in Hollywood,
shooting at cars, kind of redness.
A friend of you guys. Yeah.
We hung out with this guy. Yeah. We
hung out with this guy at the, um,
at the Canyon Club.
Yeah. And he just got shot by cops. Yeah.
He lunged towards a cop with a knife.
And I guess before right before that he
tried to overdose on drugs and you tried
to come in and stuff where the cop Kellum
yeah, yeah. She was dead. Yeah, he's dead.
Whoa. Yeah. What do you mean moderator?
He's a moderate or a message board.
Like he's, he, uh, we have
a message board. It's very,
it's a huge mess of boards going
like more than 5 million posts on it.
And this guy was one of the monitoring.
It's kind of like one of the guys
that lives here more than once.
We hang out with him more
than once. Yeah. Yeah.
He was actually gonna I was gonna try and
get him to train my dog. Yeah, he was,
he wanting to train my dogs too.
When I, when I have those pit bulls,
he was always trying to tell me
he's going to come over and fix him.
What'd you have pit bulls for? Um,
I love them. I grow up with them.
They're just really smart dogs.
You know,
I'd really became too much of
a pain in the ass. I got older.
I don't like the dog aggressiveness.
Know I have a massive,
now is just the opposite. He
doesn't, he never wants to,
he doesn't hate dog at all. And it mix it
up. If he gets close to dogs, he's like,
Hey, what's up? You know, he's like,
he's the big silly, but it was just,
I loved them with people.
They were the most affectionate,
intelligent dogs of people. It really
make a great connection with them.
And I grew up with them.
But the real issue is when you
have them around other dogs,
they're just too crazy too,
is the,
the all the years and years
and years of conditioning,
you can't get it out of their system.
They've had generation after generation
of calling the dogs that would not fight
or would quit. You know? So what,
what it comes out to is survival of the
fittest while they're so smart and quick
and they're so loyal and they also
kill all the dogs that show any human
aggression because he's, you know,
when they may breed these dogs to find,
they would have to be able to get in and
separate them. So if the dog, you know,
turns on you and bite you,
they would get rid of all those dogs.
So there were like nonhuman aggressive,
really intelligent survival
dogs and they're there.
There's really fucking brilliant animals,
but they're too crazy.
I think you need to shit to greed of
the wall sits who's a really cute,
they're all,
they all come from walls,
which is really fucking crazy and no one
really understands. I know by the way,
people have sent me a
bunch of things here.
They explain it how dogs
came from all I've read it.
It's a lot of fucking guesswork
and patchwork. You can't take,
you show me one fucking guy ever who's
taken a wolf and turn it into a Chihuahua.
We show me showing that they can do, they
have done some pretty amazing, not that,
but when in in trying to explain
how that could have happened.
They've done some pretty amazing selective
breeding with Fox. Yes, they have.
I have change it like
dogs 10,000 years ago,
they did this shit a long time,
over a period of time that
we have a really almost
difficult time comprehending.
Yeah, I know, but it's still, I mean
it's amazing that it's been done. I mean,
I'm not doubting they did call come
from wolves. Absolutely did. I mean,
I mean I believe at 100% geneticists
have proven all variations on we'll know
for sure. But it is hard. You
know it's hard. Flash lived.
You'd wind up with like a,
like a mini poodles are.
When I say I'm incredulous,
it's not that I'm not,
maybe it's just like that can't even
wrap my head around the [inaudible] Wolf
and 12 hug. They turn a wolf into
a fucking French poodle. Like what?
What, why? Yeah, what the fuck happened?
If I could wave a magic wand and have
them all go back to wolves, I work.
Cause it's like it'd be more enjoyable
to have him around. I don't know man.
It's kind of cool when people have a
little Chihuahua and they keep it in their
bag and you're like, hey little
buddy. It's nothing wrong with that.
But it is really a sign of what we
are, you know, we are just like,
I mean if you wanted to look at people,
people are the only thing that
would like dogs. You know,
we vary so much in size
and shape and looks,
and yet we can breed with each other. You
know, it's really quite strange, dude.
You are a great spokesman for the idea
of hunting and for an intelligent well
read person who appreciates it for,
for what it really is. You know?
And I think your, your stance on is
admirable and your stance against it,
you know, the high fence
and the, the, you know,
just the ethics that you have towards it.
It's a lot of people can learn from it.
I think in a lot of people can learn.
And it's one of the things that I took
from your show that a, it's not just a,
you know, being a sportsman, if there's,
there's discipline to it and that
you benefit from that discipline.
And what you were talking
about when you're talking
about how when you're in the
state of hunting that you're
not thinking about anything.
You're just totally in the group.
That zen state is what everyone is
looking for in martial arts and in that
playing pool and it's
doing standup comedy,
that Zen state of being completely
in the moment, you know,
and that's chasing that down. Um, and uh,
I've always been a big supporter
of trying to, you know,
be self sustainable practice what I
preach and a fucking buy bottled water.
I would really,
I'd like to pull it off Sunday.
I like to pull it off and I think
what you're doing is brilliant. So uh,
people want to see your show.
They can catch it on the,
what does the network
outdoors on sportsman channel.
What I would have been fine as is
go to www, the meat eater.com. Okay.
Check that out. Um, I got a Twitter
account of at Steven Rinella.
S. T. E. V. E. N. R. I. N. Yeah,
we've got that linkedin and we'll,
we'll, we'll tweak that up later. Uh,
thanks for coming man.
Hey man, awesome. Really,
really cool conversation and good luck
on the new show. I loved your old show.
I'm sure are going to
love your new show too.
I'm gonna start t vote on it
tonight. Bitches. Thanks to a,
the flashlight for sponsoring
our fabulous program. Oh,
Chicago theater almost sold out.
You dirty freaks.
That's not more than two weeks away.
What does it 10 days away? What's today?
The 10 days away. The 27th, me,
Joey Diaz and Duncan Trussell Chicago
theater shit is going to be off the chain
and Mike Maxwell has made a special
limited edition poster that a,
he's going to be selling.
You made only a couple hundred of those
and we're going to be selling them and
he'll sign them and shit at the arena.
And that right there.
Is it like underneath that role? It's not
done yet. Now he hasn't finished it yet.
That's something else, but that's it. All
right, thanks to the flashlight for oh,
go to Joe rogan.net for anything you're
looking forward toward dates or any of
that shit. Um, uh,
the next one also February 3rd
house of Blues and that's us, me,
Joey Diaz, and someone
else. Ari can't do it,
but maybe Dunkin fucking drag him away
from his girlfriend if he's allowed to
leave the house.
Hey everybody,
thanks to the flashlight
for sponsoring our program.
Whenever you want to call this fucking
thing. If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the flashlight
and enter in the code name rogue and you
will get 15% off.
Number one sex toy from man.
Thanks to [inaudible] dot com for
sponsoring us as well. O, n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom,
tech, sport, shroom, tech,
immune and new mood as we
say with all on it products.
It's 100% money back guarantee if you
don't like it and just go steal the
ingredients and make it yourself if you
think it costs too much. Okay, so sample.
We love all you dirty freaks out there
in internet land and we appreciate you
very much for tuning into the show and
this will never end. See you soon. Bye.
Okay.